la question dont nous allons traiter la
question de la fin de vie qui suscite
tant et tant de débat
c'est d'abord une question intime
le moment où chacun d'entre nous se
trouve confronté à
cette inéluctable là en tout cas il
déductable jusqu'à maintenant
alors ça suscite des débats extrêmement
éruptif
parce que
s'ajoute à cette question intime une
question
philosophique on va dire d'idéologie
personnelle chacun qui
s'est fait un engagement sur ce sujet là
et c'est pourquoi je n'ai pas voulu le
prendre nous n'avons pas voulu le
prendre
par
la démarche ou l'angle du débat
le prendre par l'angle de l'échange
pour un premier échange entre
des
femmes et des hommes
des professionnels et simplement des
aidants
qui ont fait l'expérience de long terme
de la rencontre de la mort
la rencontre vivante de la mort la
rencontre des vivants avec la mort
donc on va faire le tour chacun va se
présenter
en commencera par Jean Leonetti qui a
joué un si grand rôle
moi je dis souvent pour me faire voter
un texte sur la fin de vie il fallait
être fort
et j'ai voté son texte
en pleine conscience
et je ne l'ai jamais regretté depuis et
donc Jean Leonetti a eu a eu la
gentillesse de venir participer à notre
rencontre c'est le premier qui va se
présenter et puis on va tourner Alice en
passant par toi à toi Jean
dans les Hauts-de-Seine et secrétaire
général adjointe au modèle
je suis avocat
une présence de chroniqueurs et
essayer j'ai publié fin de vie en
république au début de l'année 2022 et
je suis bénévole en soins palliatifs
depuis bientôt un an
je suis médecin responsable d'un service
de soins palliatifs plutôt dans les
Hauts-de-Seine je travaille depuis 12
ans et je suis vice-présidente de la
Isabelle marin moi je suis médecin
retraité mais j'ai travaillé pendant 30
ou 40 ans à Saint-Denis dans le 93 où
j'étais aussi responsable de la
précarité et j'ai travaillé également
dans un lame qui est un lieu d'accueil
de grand malade sans papiers et donc et
puis j'ai été il y a quelques temps
secrétaire général pas si longtemps
et actuellement je travaille en
Bourgogne parce que vous savez qu'il y a
peut-être des désher médicaux et la
Bourgogne en est un et donc
Anne le gagne je suis gériat je
travaille à l'hôpital public depuis 23
ans d'abord à l'hôpital de Saint-Malo et
actuellement à Rennes et conseillère
municipal à Saint-Malo
Marie de Henzel je suis psychologue
clinicienne et je suis la psychologue
qui est entrée dans la première unité de
soins palliatifs créée en France en 1987
j'ai écrit un livre qui a été connu dans
le monde entier la morale team justement
sur les aspects intimes de cette
expérience de faire face à la mort et
d'être l'accompagnement puis chargé de
mission ministère de la Santé et je
continue à m'intéresser à cette question
surtout du point de vue des personnes
âgées que je rencontre depuis 15 ans
pierre pour cadre moi je suis médecin ne
sont palliatifs à Narbonne dans l'Aude
dans un département rural le plus pauvre
de France et je suis président de la
société française d'accompagnement ne
soit palliatifs depuis deux ans et demi
bonjour Marie Grosset je suis magistrate
et j'ai écrit plusieurs articles sur la
relation entre la justice et la question
de la fin de vie et voilà et j'ai été
aussi directrice adjointe des services
juridiques de l'Assistance Publique des
Hôpitaux de Paris pendant 2 ans et demi
où j'ai beaucoup été confronté à ce type
de situation
bonsoir à tous donc je suis Anne Therese
je suis élu à Louviers premier adjointe
également vice-présidente du conseil
départemental de l'Eure où j'exerce la
délégation autonomie donc personne âgée
personne handicapées la lutte contre les
exclusions la santé et je suis
secrétaire général adjointe du MoDem
bonsoir maux de Gatel je suis député de
Paris et secrétaire général du Mouvement
Démocrate
très bien
donc si vous voulez bien
je rappelle donc avec l'accord de tout
le monde la conversation parce que c'est
une conversation et filmée elle sera
disponible sur
les réseaux sociaux et sur nos sites
mais ça n'est pas
dans mon esprit
confrontation de prise de position
publique
dans mon esprit ce qui m'intéresse
c'est ce que vous vivez j'ai passé une
après-midi avec le service de soins
palliatifs à Pau
tout le monde
jusque
comment s'appelle la dame qui fait les
repas et
bien sûr les aides soignants et
c'était
extrêmement intéressant c'était je
trouve que c'est si le mot vocation a un
sens
c'est une vocation
c'est une vocation donnée aux autres
donner aux autres dans le moment
où il n'y a rien à attendre
c'est donc
[Musique]
gratuit rien à attendre sauf la lumière
dans le regard qui qui dit quelque chose
de d'impossible à éluder
et les yeux dans les yeux
donc claire on va peut-être commencer
par vous puisque vous êtes en charge
présidente de
l'association qui réunit tous les
médecins ou presque tous les médecins ne
sont pas natifs tous les soignants tous
les soignants elle est
pluridisciplinaire depuis sa naissance
parce que les soins palliatifs ça peut
pas se faire c'est pas une affaire de
médecin c'est vraiment une affaire
d'équipe parce que justement faire face
à la mort c'est possible qu'en équipe
c'est pas possible seul parce qu'on
passe avec nos patients une promesse de
non-abandon on les laissera pas tomber
quoi qu'il arrive on sera là jusqu'au
bout et que cette promesse elle peut se
tenir que collectivement et donc depuis
ses débuts l'ASPAP a toujours été
pluridisciplinaire et non seulement il y
a des soignants mais il y a aussi des
bénévoles qui viennent dire aussi que
c'est l'affaire aussi de toute la
société et pas seulement l'affaire des
soignants et je trouve ça c'est un
message très important alors juste vous
avez dit qu'il y a rien à attendre pour
nous soignants mais ce qu'on reçoit je
veux dire rien à attendre
de
l'ordre
des gratifications habituelles et en
tout cas ça donne là c'est mieux je
parle à mon nom personnel puisque vous
avez dit ça donne du sens à la vie aussi
pour nous parce que du coup ça rend la
fin ça permet de voir à combien la vie
est précieuse combien elle peut basculer
rapidement combien avec fragile et
combien c'est important de la vie chaque
moment donc ça c'est on reçoit
énormément sinon on pourrait pas tenir
mais en même temps on ne peut tenir
aussi que parce qu'on est en équipe et
donc c'est à dire qu'on prend la parole
collectivement c'est pas une affaire de
soignants c'est pas une affaire de
médecin c'est pas seulement une affaire
de soignant mais c'est vraiment une
affaire de toute la société et nous
c'est ce qu'on voudrait partager dans ce
débat actuel c'est l'idée que que c'est
pas qu'un débat d'expert mais que c'est
important que chacun entende prenne
puisse réfléchir comprendre les enjeux
parce que il me semble que c'est toute
la société qui doit accompagner et que
nous soignants qui faisons un métier
difficile nous accompagnant en tout cas
la confrontation régulière à la mort est
difficile c'est pas la mort une fois qui
est difficile c'est la répétition de de
l'accompagnement de la perte de
l'attachement du lien qui se fait puis
qui se défait et et on a besoin on est
là au nom de la société c'est parce que
ça a du sens pour notre société d'être
là qu'on peut tenir au quotidien et je
pense qu'en ce moment il y a une très
grande inquiétude de tout ce monde de
l'accompagnement et pas seulement
palliatifs mais de beaucoup de soignants
parce qu'on a l'impression que si la
société nous fait défaut avant de qui on
sera là le nombre de qui on affrontera
la maladie la mort
parfois dur c'est parfois pas beau à
voir c'est parfois on a envie de s'en
aller et on est là parce que ça a du
sens collectivement et si ça n'a plus de
sens pour d'autres collectif ça devient
beaucoup plus difficile pour nous tous
d'être là et donc on a besoin de vous de
chacun pour pouvoir
être au nom de tous présents et je
trouve que c'est ce que la loi actuelle
dit elle dit vous comptez pour nous ça a
du sens pour nous de vous accompagner
quoi qu'il en coûte on va vous soulager
on va être là si si on a plus ce ça pour
nous tenir
ça sera beaucoup plus compliqué pour
nous merci beaucoup Jean est-ce que je
peux te demander de résumer pour ceux
qui nous écouterons
les évolutions législatives quand tu as
commencé à t'engager sur ce sujet quand
tu as fait ta loi quand tu l'as partagé
en fin quelles ont été les mouvements et
est-ce que tu peux nous faire un bilan
de ce que tu analyses aujourd'hui sur
qui va servir de base au débat
naturellement
qui va pas être ça d'abord merci merci
François de m'avoir invité et de
remettre tes pieds dans cette maison
avec un brin de nostalgie
il y a plusieurs lois et aucune n'est
appliquée c'est la première constatation
les soins palliatifs sont opposables à
chaque fois un citoyen j'entends de
temps en temps des gens qui disent mais
il faudrait que ce soit que chaque
citoyen y est droit c'est fait c'est
fait dans le texte c'est pas fait dans
la vie
22 départements sont des produits
d'unité de soins palliatifs le deuxième
c'est la loi 2002 c'est une loi qui rend
de l'autonomie aux patient et qui permet
au fond de des verticaliser si le terme
est juste une relation qui était assez
paternaliste entre les médecins et le
malade
le code d'énergie dit que c'est deux
confiance et de conscience dans ce
contexte là bien c'est le malade qui
pilote sa vie qui pilote le médecin est
clair
l'équipe accompagne et le malade dit ça
j'en veux et ça j'en veux pas en toute
connaissance de cause
2005 c'est la loi
[Musique]
de parlementaire
je rappelle qu'on fait un rapport à la
demande du président et que c'est à
cette époque là la gauche y compris la
gauche communiste qui vient et qui dit
si tu écris ce qu'on écrit ensemble on
en fait une loi
ce qui
est plus jamais arrivé donc je pense pas
que ça arrive très très souvent et donc
finalement heureusement que Dominique
Perben et Philippe 12 loisirs ont
accepté que cette loi soit pas modifiée
par les par les ministères mais au fond
la loi dit trois choses elle dit je
t'abandonne pas combien de lire clair je
te laisserai pas souffrir il y a une
transgression dont je te laisse repasse
souffrir puisqu'on accepte ce qu'on
appelle le double effet c'est à dire si
je peux te soulager même si dans le
deuxième texte il y a même si même si
cela doit raccourcir ta vie donc là la
souffrance est interdite
cette époque là il y avait un rapport
lors de la deuxième Loire rapport SICAR
qui disait que 12% des patients à
l'AP-HP
mourait avec des douleurs insupportables
douleurs pas des souffrances des
douleurs donc facile à calmer et ça ne
se faisait pas voilà donc on a je
t'abandonnerai pas je te laisserai pas
souffrir je te prolongerai pas de
manière anormale ce qui est un peu plus
compliqué en fait c'est la chargement
thérapeutique dans le dans l'esprit
public et c'est ce que les médecins
depuis longtemps à peine obstination des
raisonnable c'est mieux que charlesment
thérapeutique les cardiologues
réanimateurs commencent beaucoup agir et
avec des traitements et ma foi on le
regrette pas trop par contre
l'obstination des raisonnable c'est une
démarche qui nie la réalité il va mourir
et je continue à faire comme s'il était
vivant et comme s'il est vivant en fait
je me protège je suis de ceux qui
pensent que l'acharnement thérapeutique
et l'euthanasie ça relève de la même
démarche c'est à dire une négation de la
mort une incapacité à accepté et à la
compagnie donc on y met des directives
anticipées et on y ajoute à personne de
confiance qui peut parler à la place du
malade donc les deux petits révolutions
qui sont pas si petites c'est on accepte
de soulager la souffrance au prix
peut-être de raccourcir la vie parce que
la qualité de vie en fin de vidéo prime
sur la durée de la vie et on accepte
d'arrêter ou de ne pas mettre en oeuvre
des traitements salvateurs sur la base
d'un constat évident qui est tout ce qui
est techniquement et scientifiquement
possible n'est pas obligatoirement
humainement souhaitable
dans ce contexte là ça faisait longtemps
qu'on a arrêté les respirateurs en réa
et on le faisait de manière clandestine
avec une situation particulière je
racontais tout à l'heure à l'école de
magistrature une anecdote qui est
amusante parce qu'on demande à notre
Conseil d'État
il me dit quand vous arrêtez le
respirateur est-ce que le malade va
mourir est-ce que vous le savez oui
quand on arrête la respirateur mourir
est-ce que vous décidez ça tout seul ou
ou vous concertez en concert bien sûr en
équipe et est-ce que vous le faites de
manière impulsive ou bien ce que vous le
réfléchissez je n'ai pas le réfléchir un
peu d'avance quand même et il dit bah
c'est un homicide en bande d'organiser
avec préméditation donc ce qui est la
définition pénale de l'homicide avec
l'homicide il est défini c'est une
qualification puis ensuite on regarde le
juge on regarde les circonstances et
l'opportunité
je vais prendre ça de l'opportunité des
poursuites donc et les médecins avaient
ça dans la tête et ça les terroriser et
donc ça faisait une clandestinité un non
dit et
si je peux rappeler notre anecdote la
première fois que je suis rentré dans
les services de soins palliatifs j'ai
pas compris moi dans mon service tout le
monde courait tout le monde se battait
pour la vie à tout prix c'est normal
c'est un service qui t'a fait pour ça et
on faisait le cardiologie oui et en face
de bilan et quand on disait on a quatre
morts comment quatre morts d'infarctus
cette semaine mais ressortez les
dossiers etc et là ils étaient tous
sereins ils avaient ils étaient
illuminés voilà ça m'a fait écrire un
livre qui s'appelait la lumière du
crépuscule parce que Claire le dira
mieux que moi mais en fait le malade qui
part
éclaire le soignant c'est pas une c'est
pas vertical c'est pas le soignant qui
vient au secours du malade Morand le
malade mourant apporte quelque chose il
apporte une forme de de lumière de de
d'essentiel d'authentique qui qui
irradie à l'intérieur des soignants
c'est pour ça qu'ils étaient sereins
donc je t'abandonnerai pas je te
laisserai pas souffrir je te prolongerai
pas de manière normale en 2016 la
situation est un peu différente le
président Hollande a pris un engagement
de campagne mais cet engagement de
campagne
j'ai oublié de dire que c'était à la
suite l'affaire Vincent Humbert que le
premier loi a été voté
l'engagement de campagne est ambivalent
pour pas dire ambigu il est il dit je
souhaite que chaque citoyen puisse avoir
une aide médicale pour mourir dans la
dignité située pro euthanasie tu dis
l'ADMD c'est moi et si tu es soins
palliatif tu dis l'accompagnement c'est
moi et donc le président choisit deux
députés un dans sa majorité dans
l'opposition et donc on a mission là de
faire un texte de faire un texte
législatif et on se base sur le rapport
Sicard le rapport Sicard dit la Parole
du malade n'est pas assez entendu perte
d'un manque de respect de l'autonomie de
la personne et pour autant en fin de vie
on meurt encore mal en France c'est la
phrase qu'il avait utilisé parce qu'on
souffre encore
donc on rajoute quelque chose qui qui
sont techniques on rajoute que les
personnes de confiance a plus de pouvoir
on solidifie les directives anticipées
et on installe la sédation profonde et
continue je connaissais le droit de
dormir pour ne pas souffrir quand la fin
de vie est proche et que la souffrance
est réfractaire donc
les deux lois passaient uneanimité la
première dans un mouvement
un peu un peu rêvé de de l'Union de la
Droite et de la gauche et des
parlementaires et du centre et du centre
me semble-t-il ce que disait Mitterrand
le centre ne dit pas de bêtises c'est ni
à gauche ni à gauche
je suis un centre droit donc dans ce
contexte là enfin l'unanimité se passe
avec un soutien des communistes comme
j'ai jamais vu avec des communistes
totalement engagés et c'est pas étonnant
d'ailleurs parce que au fond dans cette
danse conflit de valeurs entre une
éthique de l'autonomie qui est une
éthique de la liberté et une éthique de
la vulnérabilité qui est une éthique de
la solidarité de la fraternité
c'est un peu le combat aussi du jeu
contre le nous je dis c'est mon choix et
nous te répondons nous te protégeons
voilà et nous te protégeons malgré toi
je t'empêche de te tuer je t'empêche de
te droguer je t'empêche de te mutiler je
t'empêche de te prostituer parce que la
part d'humanité qui est en toi tu peux
pas l'altérer sinon tu altères
l'humanité tout entière donc moi pour
moi les bases fondamentales de de ne pas
donner
c'est c'est des bases humaines c'est pas
c'est pas des bases qui sont sur la
croyance ou la foi ça peut en rajouter
mais en tout cas on peut ne pas avoir la
foi et défendre la position qui est
celle-là alors on a fait des lois pour
les gens qui vont mourir comme disait à
miel
un sénateur socialiste du Sud je dis du
Sud encore un peu plus sympathique et
pas pour les gens qui veulent mourir et
donc en fait tu peux en voter 30 fois
des lois à l'unanimité il y a un faux
débat le vrai débat vous voulez que la
loi s'applique donner les moyens pour le
faire
et je rajouterai que le problème c'est
que si on fait une loi ou on a
une aide active à mourir ce qui en fait
une hypocrisie des termes qui en fait de
donner la mort c'est un homicide ça
s'appelle comme ça
faudra pas changer les lois
d'accompagnement il faut changer le loi
droit pénal il faut trouver une
dépénalisation à l'homicide par
compassion ou une raison donc on va pas
plus loin on va ailleurs
quand on dit on va faire une loi pour
les gens qui veulent mourir et donc la
question se pose est-ce que ce droit
liberté que j'ai de me suicider est-ce
que c'est un droit créant qui je peux
réclamer à la société
et je le crois pas et je crois qu'une
société qui a un moment donné ouvre la
brèche de donner la mort c'est ma
position personnelle
après je sais qu'il y a d'autres
stratégies et d'autres tactiques moi je
pense que c'est un interdit majeur voilà
et j'ai un interdit majeur et je le
répète demain je débat avec
le président des évêques de France
qui dans les frères Amazon qui dit si
Dieu n'existe pas tout est permis
je pense l'inverse moi je pense que le
parc de Pascal il doit être inversé si
Dieu n'existe pas rien n'est permis
parce que j'ai toute la responsabilité
de l'humanité j'ai toute la
responsabilité de cette part de dignité
qu'on a chacun entre nous et dont on est
responsable et on est donc responsable
de l'autre pas forcément en fraternité
face à la divinité ça peut se concevoir
mais au directement voilà les vinasses
je vois le visage de l'autre il est moi
et il est un autre et parce qu'il est
moi et un autre je ne peux pas le tuer
voilà c'est c'est fondamental et j'ai
bien peur que cette c'est la
transgression essentielle à mes yeux de
donner la mort j'ai avoué donc je le ré
à vous ici que j'ai voté Mitterrand en
91 sur un sujet un seul il abolissait la
peine de mort parce que donner la mort à
l'autre c'est une acte de barbarie qui
l'interdit fondamental de la vie en
société si demain je peux donner à mort
en dehors de la légitime défense ou de
la guerre juste
je pense qu'à ce moment-là comme dans
tous les pays où ça s'est passé on
élargit gentiment les problèmes alors je
rentre pas dans le débat sur
l'euthanasie et suicide assister j'ai
dit publiquement
que j'estimais parce que ça impliquait
moins les médecins que ça posait moins
de problèmes que c'était un moindre mal
le suicide assisté typorégan que le
tanazi type belge mais
j'ai vu que j'ai dit au président de la
République mais ce moindre mal est un
mal voilà et je me suis aperçu qu'en
fait j'avais piqué cette phrase à Anna à
Arendt qui qui dit le vrai danger c'est
que quand on fait un moindre mal très
rapidement ce qu'ils le font oublie que
c'est un mal
merci beaucoup Jean pour eux pour tout
ça pour pour ces années là et qui sont
précieuses je voudrais vous interroger
sur deux sujets
le premier sujet je voudrais que les
soignants ou accompagnants parmi vous
nous raconte
d'abord comment ils sont entrés dans
dans cette vocation et comment il arrive
humainement personnellement avec ce dont
vous avez la charge premier sujet
puis-je vous interrogerai après sur
l'état de la situation est-ce que les
gens souffrent comme disent les gens
encore
combien est-ce qu'on pourrait supprimer
complètement la souffrance quel serait
les réactions si on supprimait
complètement leur
douleur
physique
ressentie
bref
tu disais la loi les deux lois aucune
des deux lois d'établiquées vraiment
mais combien de moyens ça représenterait
enfin toutes ces toutes ces questions là
alors on va commencer
on va commencer
par vous clair rapidement comment vous
êtes arrivés à ça alors pardon parce
qu'on en a déjà parlé ensemble beaucoup
mais on va recommencer
moi j'y suis arrivée sans savoir qu'ils
sont en palliatifs existait mais quand
j'étais étudiante j'ai commencé je
voulais être réanimatrice néonatale
j'avais jamais mis les pieds à l'hôpital
et j'avais cette idée là et en fait j'ai
fait d'abord un premier stage en cancéro
où j'ai été très frappé de la façon dont
les patients étaient abandonnés
complètement enfin comment la mort se
passait derrière des portes fermées et
concernées uniquement les paramédicaux
c'est à dire c'était des infirmières qui
s'en occupaient mais à quel point les
médecins étaient complètement
indifférent au sujet à cette époque là
on avait demandé avec les autres
externes les autres étudiants en
médecine une formation sur l'annonce et
on nous a répondu c'est des tartes à la
crème pour les médias je me rappelle
comme si enfin
voilà ça n'intéressait pas du tout et je
suis passé après juste après dans un
service de patient au VIH donc des
patients sida à l'époque c'était le
début des trithérapies et donc des
patients jeunes informés qui étaient
vraiment des partenaires de soins de de
des soignants enfin qui qui étaient
vraiment acteurs de la maladie et où je
me suis dit voilà il y a quelque chose
de différent qui est possible et qui
c'est vraiment intéressant et du coup je
partais au Canada et deux ans j'ai formé
aux soins palliatifs et découvert aussi
à monde beaucoup moins pyramidal et
vraiment ce travail en équipe horizontal
qui est vraiment d'une grande richesse
Marie
alors moi que c'est à l'époque où j'ai
François Mitterrand m'a proposé d'être
la psychologue de la première univers
qui s'est créée en 87 il faut savoir que
c'était il y avait trois ans avant de
fameux colloque de Nice dans lequel on a
découvert que et bien on euthanasier
finalement illégalement les patients en
fin de vie en leur posant un cocktail
lithique et que c'était des pratiques
illégales bien sûr secrètes et la France
entière a découvert que c'était ces
pratiques là parce que effectivement
avant on mourait chez soi et puis
progressivement on est à l'hôpital sans
que les médecins étaient formés sans
qu'il y ait eu aussi les moyens de
soulager la douleur que l'on a ensuite
découvert donc quand je suis arrivée là
avec une équipe
qui était pionnière nous nous n'avions
aucune formation il y avait juste le
service de
[Musique]
Montréal qui était ouvert et qui était
un petit peu notre notre boussole il y
avait le mouvement des hospices à
Londres avec la découverte aussi du
justement de la morphine des effets de
la morphine et ce que ce que je voudrais
dire ce qui m'a beaucoup frappée et
c'est une initiative que j'ai eu mais
qui a été fondamentale je crois dans le
vécu de par l'équipe de ce que nous
vivions qui était nous accueillons ce
petit service qui accueillait des
patients qu'on ne pouvait plus guérir
dont on savait qu'ils allaient mourir
j'avais réuni toute l'équipe docteur
Abiven jusqu'à la personne chargée des
repas et je leur avais dit parlons
passons une matinée entière à parler de
la mort comment la mort nous a frappé
dans nos vies
parce que si nous commençons pas par là
je vois pas comment est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire ce travail pionnier et le
docteur abivven qui est mort aujourd'hui
a commencé en racontant le suicide de
son fils et il a une larme qui a coulé
le long de sa joue et ensuite l'autre
médecin docteur Camberlin puis les
soignants les uns après les autres
tout le monde a parlé de bien de la mort
d'un grand-père d'une grand-mère d'un
conjoint d'un enfant
on s'est aperçu que tout le monde moi
j'ai parlé du suicide de mon père qui
était certainement pour beaucoup dans
dans tout mon engagement et dont mes
positions aussi on s'est aperçu que tout
le monde avait souffert de la mort que
personne n'y échappe et en sortant une
infirmière m'a pris par le bras et elle
m'a dit Marie je ne verrais plus jamais
mes collègues de la même manière je sais
que nous sommes les humains
qui sommes confrontés à la mort et c'est
avec en sachant cela et en faisant
solidarité que nous allons accompagner
d'autres patients et leur famille et je
voyais ce pour moi ça a été le moment
fondateur et cette équipe dans laquelle
j'ai été la psychologue pendant 9 ans
est une équipe dans lesquelle il y avait
aucun absentéisme il faut le savoir
parce que aucun absentéisme c'était
remarquable dans l'hôpital pourquoi
parce que je crois que chaque soignant à
quelques niveaux qu'ils soient avaient
le sentiment comme vous l'avez dit de
recevoir beaucoup de faire quelque chose
d'extraordinaire qui était
il recevait sans doute beaucoup plus
qu'il ne donnait et dans ce monde qui
était rejeté enfin nous baignons dans
tout ce que la société
rejetée tout ce qui était le rebut de la
société de la maladie la mort
tout ça dans le mensonge à l'époque il
faut pas oublier que c'était la comédie
du mensonge on ne disait pas les choses
comme on les dit aujourd'hui et bien il
y avait justement cette lumière
peut-être cette douceur qui qui était là
au milieu de cette de cette horreur et
je crois que
[Musique]
tous les soignants
ce ils l'ont dit d'une manière ou d'une
autre il disait que le soir quand il
rentrait chez eux et bien il se rendait
compte que je me souviens d'une
infirmière qui m'avait dit ça me dit je
ne veux plus jamais d'ardoise si je me
suis disputée avec quelqu'un je prends
mon téléphone et je règle parce que je
sais à quel point la vie est précaire
que ça peut nous tomber dessus à
n'importe quoi et donc je me suis rendu
compte que ce travail c'était une vraie
c'est une vraie méditation sur la mort
qui s'est faite au quotidien
et il y avait donc cette solidarité
c'est
tout ça dans dans la mort intime donc
ensuite c'est vrai que j'ai quitté le
travail clinique mais aujourd'hui alors
je ne suis pas vraiment dans le travail
clinique dans la présente au chevet mais
j'ai je me suis beaucoup intéressée à la
manière dont on meurt dans les EHPAD
j'ai pendant un an travaillé avec un
groupe privé
pour améliorer les conditions de et je
me suis rendu compte à quel point les
choses se passaient mal parce que
personne ne voulait parler de la mort la
mort était complètement il y avait un
secret il s'était-il on était incapable
de s'asseoir auprès d'une personne
âgée qui pouvait avoir laver des
questions des peurs qu'il y avait envie
de parler de ce qu'elle ce qu'elle avait
envie peut-être de transmettre il y
avait personne ne pouvait s'asseoir là
et juste je me suis rendu compte de
vraiment de justement de cette absence
de culture
palliative et
est-ce que je peux juste ajouter quelque
chose parce que ça me paraît très
important au moment où j'ai fait deux
rapports le rapport
en
fin de ville de voir d'accompagnement
mais j'ai fait un deuxième rapport qui
était la France palliative à la demande
de Philippe Douste Blazy j'étais partie
faire le tour de France des régions et
partout dans tout je voyais dans chaque
région un hôpital un CHU un hôpital
général et un hôpital local et
c'était on avait demandé que tout le
monde tous les services soient
représentés et je me suis rendu compte
que quand tout le monde est rassemblé et
entend la même chose
sur quoi sur la loi sur votre loi sur ce
qu'elle disait sur toutes les questions
qui pouvaient se poser quand tout le
monde se met ensemble pour parler et
bien il y a un début de culture
dans mon rapport j'ai demandé je me
souviens que le Président de la
République la l'époque c'était Nicolas
Sarkozy et bien
disent qu'il souhaitait que dans tous
les hôpitaux partout l'on meurt on est
une fois par an une réunion
d'information
sur la fin de vie de sensibilisation et
qu'elle soit obligatoire j'avais demandé
dans ma mesure que chaque service envoie
au moins trois
médecins une infirmière et
aide-soignante et on m'a répondu c'est
impossible
j'ai demandé pourquoi on m'a dit c'est
impossible de rendre obligatoire une
réunion sur la fin de vie
alors qu'on rendait obligatoire ou des
réunions sur la maladie nosocomiale et
sur la fin de vie ce n'était pas
possible donc ça n'était pas argumenté
on m'a juste répondu non et bien moi je
pense maintenant que si on avait mis ça
en place
cette cette réunion annuelle partout
l'on meurt on en serait pas là
se parler ensemble et pour moi la clé
ils ont serait sorti de ce je dirais de
ce cette peur de la mort de ce tabou de
la mort c'est l'expérience des uns par
exemple les soins palliatifs auraient pu
à chaque année parler comme
voilà témoigner de ce qu'ils vivent les
autres auraient entendu soirée cheminée
les gens reviennent dans leur famille
dans leur famille qu'est-ce qu'ils font
le soir ils disent tiens on a une
réunion à l'hôpital sur la fin de vie
parlons-en parce que dans les familles
aussi on en parle pas c'est motus et
bouche cousu partout c'est moi tu sais
bouche cousues
et le paradoxe c'est qu'on va avoir une
loi sur la fin de vie
qui va être
qui va vraiment donc on verra
merci Marie Anne alors toi tu es génial
moi je suis je suis riades j'étais pas
du tout prédestinée à être gériatrième
initialement je suis urgentiste où
j'étais au cœur au cœur de la gitation
au cas au cœur du combat du combat
contre pour la vie et contre et contre
la mort et je suis parti un an en Inde
ça a été assez fulgurant comme espace
comme espace de de lumière dans ma vie
et c'est un moment effectivement où je
me suis je me suis dit que sans doute je
m'étais trompé je m'étais trompé de
spécialités
parce que j'ai réfléchi beaucoup aux
Intouchables aux invisibles et lorsque
je suis lorsque je suis rentré je me
suis dit que ma place n'était
certainement plus dans le service
d'urgence mais plutôt dans un service de
gériatrie près des plus fragiles et plus
vulnérables des invisibles des
intouchables en tous les cas de ceux que
l'on regarde que l'on regarde peu qui
sont dans des EHPAD qui à l'époque il y
avait pas beaucoup de lits de court
séjour de court séjour gériatriques donc
j'ai refait j'ai refait trois ans
d'études pour pour aller vers la vers la
gériatrie convaincue que effectivement
mais c'était aussi au cœur de nos
hôpitaux que les lettres de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité de vivre que
nous devions mettre plus d'humanité dans
dans nos soins donc c'est c'est cela moi
qui m'a amené à la gériatrie je ne l'ai
jamais je ne l'ai jamais regretté
et aujourd'hui ce serait à faire je
referai la je referai la même chose j'ai
eu 20 ans
de bonheur à travailler en équipe
avec avec des gens engagés
dans des services
qui que l'on regarde souvent
en dernier lieu dans nos hôpitaux dans
nos hôpitaux publics
encore énormément de chemin je pense à
parcourir pour accompagner la vie
jusqu'à la fin François tu as parlé de
la question de l'intime bien il y a la
question de l'intime et la question de
l'ultime de cette ultimement de vie et
de cette part d'humanité qui reste
jusqu'au bout de cette ultime moment de
vie moi j'y crois j'y crois profondément
et voilà et inscrit effectivement dans
ce que vous avez dit Monsieur Leonetti
dans une éthique du regard cher à
Levinas c'est-à-dire c'est parce que
vous me regardez que je me crois vivante
et que je vous renvoie ce visage qui
dans ce lien de fraternité nous permet
d'être vivant jusqu'au bout donc moi je
suis très honorée d'être avec vous
d'être avec vous d'être avec vous ce
soir et c'était ma part de récit
pourquoi moi je suis je suis là
merci beaucoup Anne Isabelle
moi j'étais pneumologue à Paris j'ai été
chef de clinique dans un grand service
parisien où je m'occupais de cancer du
poumon et comme je suis rapide j'ai
compris très vite que l'avenir du cancer
du poumon c'était le somme palliatif
c'est un peu une vanne mais c'est assez
vrai en fait j'ai commencé mes études au
départ de médecine et de philosophie il
fallait deux en même temps et je
travaillais donc sur l'idéologie du
discours médical je suis désolée je suis
pas du tout de votre famille politique
et donc
en 83 par exemple on a on a travaillé au
Collège international de philosophie sur
la place de la mort à l'hôpital puisque
c'est ça qui m'intéressait et ce qui
m'intéressait c'était déconstruire
justement ce que le discours de médical
avait dépressif de dominant et la mort
en est vraiment le
comment dire
le point culminant quoi donc j'ai
travaillé avec ces patients qui avaient
à cancer du pour moi et j'ai encore 87
aussi monter la première équipe mobile
de soins palliatifs à samedi à de la
fontaine dans le 93 il faut dire que
parallèlement j'étais aussi un médecin
du monde et j'étais au Chili et que je
me suis dit un moment que c'était tout à
fait idiot d'aller faire de
l'humanitaire loin alors que je pouvais
le faire chez moi et donc je suis arrivé
là alors moi j'ai travaillé en équipe
mobile de son palliatif on en a pas
beaucoup parlé parce qu'on parle
beaucoup des unités qui sont des lieux
quand même assez particulier très
différent des lieux habituels de soins
et et moi mon enjeu et mon combat c'est
plutôt que
la culture palliatif puisse entrer dans
l'ensemble des services les gens ne
meurent pas que dans les unités sont
palliatifs c'est impossible les gens
meurent en effet comme vous le dites
partout dans les EHPAD dans les hôpitaux
beaucoup moins de missiles mais surtout
à l'hôpital et donc l'enjeu c'était
d'essayer de de compagnonner les autres
les médecins les équipes de discuter en
permanence pas faire des grandes
réunions une fois par an parce que en
effet c'est pas ça qui se faisait mais
tous les jours et d'essayer tous les
jours de voir ce qu'on pouvait faire et
voilà c'est c'est après je parlerai
peut-être des particularités parce que
parce que le 93 c'est pas tout à fait la
rue de l'Université quoi et
que par exemple des choses dans la loi
comme la personne de confiance
anticipées n'ont aucun sens excusez-moi
aucun sens et et
je voudrais juste rajouter quelque chose
qui me semble extrêmement important on a
parlé de l'optimisation des raisonnable
et je crois que toute ma carrière a été
là dessus parce qu'en fait on parle de
douleur de souffrance mais la plupart
des souffrances et des douleurs de fin
de vie sont quand même liées à de a ou
parcours médical et d'ailleurs c'est par
hasard ce sont les cancéreux c'est par
hasard s'ils sont les maladies
neuroscératives c'est des patients bien
particuliers on parle très peu
d'euthanasie pour les assurano pour les
enfants cardiaques très peu il y a très
peu de demandes et l'obtientation des
raisonnable en fait il y a trois lois
depuis 99 qu'il a refusent et elle est
permanente elle est permanente tout le
temps et on parle de l'autonomie du fait
que le patient puisse décider et
évidemment il décide pas jamais il se
soumet et par contre à la fin
quelquefois on demande son avis à la fin
voilà et donc voilà je voulais dire que
ce vous parlez d'intime moi je dirais
que c'est évidemment politique que la
façon dont une société
gère la vie et la mort des citoyens
c'est évidemment politique Foucault
avait parlé du vieux pouvoir et on est
complètement là dedans et je pense que
la loi va venir probable renforcera
est-ce que je peux vous opposer juste un
argument
j'entends bien ce que vous dites en
disant c'est politique
moi je pense qu'il faut je pense je
m'exprime à titre personnel pas au nom
de famille politique à titre personnel
mais quand même
ce qu'on est les détenteurs d'un
patrimoine
philosophique on va dire l'idéal
c'est politique mais dans ce politique
là on a le droit même si on est
minoritaire de réaffirmer le caractère
inaliénable de la conscience de
l'objection de conscience de
l'affirmation de conscience
parce que l'idée que tout doit être
réglé par une norme extérieure
une idée
que pour ma part je
sur laquelle je rejoins je pense que
et notamment l'idée de faire que la
norme
règle les comportements individuels je
crois que ça ne sera pas le cas y
compris des soignants
alors je m'excuse mais il me semble que
la norme règle les comportements
actuellement par exemple des médecins
enfin le discours médical est une norme
qui règle ce qui se passe à l'hôpital et
auquel se soumettent très facilement et
très peu tout le monde se soumet pour
l'espoir d'une vie supplémentaire voire
d'une immortalité on est sous une norme
enfin alors après
moi je suis tout à fait opposé à l'idée
qui est une loi sur l'euthanasie suicide
assistée parce que je pense qu'en effet
par rapport à la solidarité ça ça
déconstruirait totalement l'histoire de
la solitude ça permettrait comme vous
l'avez dit la serment thérapeutique on
peut peut-être sur des raisonnable puis
l'euthanasie parce que c'est ce qu'on
m'avait montré quand j'étais chef de
clinique je me rappelle un jeune interne
à l'époque où c'était les cocktails qui
m'arrive et qui me dit mais chez toi on
fait quoi en fait des cocktails on en
fait pas moi tu sais je fais ce qu'on me
dit j'avais regardé comme ça et juste
après il me réanime quelqu'un qui était
en fait un monsieur cancéreux plein de
métastases de partout
il était content de la vraie aimer il
dit et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait
au lime à cocktail
c'était ça
vous dites une certaine manière la même
chose que ce que j'essaie de dire
je suis pas allé au Chili j'ai juste
voilà je suis médecin généraliste de
formation et je pense que je c'est un
certain nombre de choses qui vont
reprendre ce que tout le monde a dit qui
m'ont mené là où je suis
première des choses c'est mon mari qui
quand j'étais stage jeune interne aux
urgences tous les soirs d'hier alors tu
as sauvé des vies et je lui disais bah
non parce qu'en fait 99% de ce qu'on
fait en médecine et aux urgences surtout
quand on est médecin généraliste quand
on n'est pas chirurgien ou réanimateur
c'est plutôt de s'occuper des clochards
qu'il faut nettoyer parce qu'ils
arrivent et c'est vraiment le côté
hospitalité qu'on a peut-être un peu
perdu après j'ai eu des annonces
difficiles à des annonces difficiles des
comportements
de médecins notamment alors enfin vous
l'avez cité les médecins qui passent
devant les portes la grande visite bon
bah là on rentre pas c'est pas la peine
il est en train de mourir et on passe
des annonces médecins un pneumologue
excuse-moi personne n'est parfait qui
avait dit qu'il y avait appelé une
famille en disant j'ai eu les résultats
de la beauty de votre oncle frère je ne
sais plus bon c'est bien un concert avec
des métastases annoncé lui dites-lui ça
c'est vraiment du véridique et ça c'est
vraiment des choses 20 ans après qui
m'ont marqué
et puis la rencontre parce que c'est une
histoire de ça avec un médecin de soins
palliatif qui était à l'époque une des
pionnières parce que c'était dans le Var
chez vous et dans le Var à cette époque
là sur la région toulonnaise il y avait
un médecin de camp palliatifs c'était
quoi donc c'est pas compliqué et je me
souviens très bien de ce jour où moi
j'étais encore interne et c'était sur
des personnes âgées qui avaient des qui
arrivaient du qui avait du mal à avaler
comme souvent et du coup qui faisait des
pulmonaire et du coup enfin ce qu'on
apprend en médecine tu es pas
gastrostomise etc on leur fait un trou
dans l'estomac on leur met un tuyau pour
qu'il n'est plus avalé donc soi-disant
ça réglé le problème et en fait je
m'étais quand même aperçu au fur et à
mesure que étonnamment ça le réglait pas
parce que très souvent sur des patients
qui certes avaient une infection
pulmonaire mais qui allait qui était
plutôt stable en fait dans les 15 jours
qui suivaient la pose de ce tuyau il
mourrait et je me souviens très bien de
ce médecin qui m'a dit un jour mais en
fait on peut faire autrement et je veux
vraiment je me souviens de ce jour-là et
de là ben après tout a découlé elle m'a
expliqué et elle m'a formé et puis et
puis je suis arrivé là où j'en suis
voilà donc vraiment cette découverte que
on peut faire autrement et c'est vrai
que je rejoins tout ce qui a été dit et
j'ai rien vraiment très neuf mais c'est
ce constat qui qui est un petit peu
désespérant je dois vous le dire
qui est qu'aujourd'hui il y a encore
tellement à faire malgré toutes ces lois
que oui il y a encore de l'acharnement
oui encore les médecins sont tétanisés
par la fin de vie sont tétanisés par la
mort sont éternisés par la peur que les
gens meurent à cause d'eux moi je vois
tous les jours à l'hôpital qui est
probablement pas pire que les autres il
faudrait presque les gens meurent en
bonne santé pour être sûr que ce soit
pas de ma faute en fait c'est cette
espèce de refus de la mort qui se
décline dans tous les actes de de
tous les actes médicaux surtout je crois
vraiment les médecins portent là-dessus
une responsabilité forte les soignants
hors médecins sont pas du tout dans
cette même
dans ce même rapport ils ont les
patients dans les bras ils les regardent
ils ont regardé patients et c'est
souvent eux qui nous disent
qu'il est en train de mourir donc voilà
ce côté un peu désespérant qu'il y a
encore tant à faire et pourtant on est
encore là donc on n'est pas encore
complètement désespéré mais c'est vrai
que cette envie de porter l'idée que
on peut je pense encore vraiment qu'on
peut faire changer ça mais au prix
d'une volonté politique et et là
vraiment dans le sens noble du terme
extrêmement forte je disais à Claire
tout à l'heure et à un moment on a
décidé que ça suffisait que les gens
meurent comme ça sur les routes et
l'ensemble du pays s'est mis au pas pour
faire ralentir les gens et on a
drastiquement diminuer la mortalité
routière mais il a fallu que ce soit des
lois des répression enfin alors je
demande pas la répression en soins
palliatif mais je pense que si on veut
faire changer les choses campagnes de le
il y a besoin d'une volonté immense que
tout le monde soit derrière à la fois
sur le plan législatif sur le plan de la
formation parce qu'on dit souvent en
manque de moyens c'est évident que
manque de moyens mais on manque aussi de
formation en manque d'information
mais c'est encore possible et ce qui est
sûr
c'est que
enfin c'est ça que c'est ça que
j'appelle c'est ça que j'aspire vous
parliez de fraternité vous parlez plein
de choses je suis 100% d'accord avec
vous et
dans ce dans ce paysage là auquel
j'aspire et auquel aspire autour de moi
les gens avec qui je travaille je veux
dire je sais mon avis personnel mais
c'est aussi la vie des soignante qui
sont autour de moi et qui souvent
d'ailleurs vient me voir il me voit pas
très souvent parce que je suis beaucoup
à la SFA mais ils viennent me voir ils
disent on compte sur toi enfin on sait
que tant que tu es là ça ira
j'essaye de pas trop les déprimer par 3h
je suis pas complètement sûr que ça ira
tant que je suis là mais voilà je pense
que dans cette société auquel j'aspire
et dans cette médecine auquel j'aspire
la place de la mort provoquée
il y a pas il y a pas de place pour la
mort provoquer parce que la mort
provoquée euthanasie suicide assisté
tout ça c'est pas compatible avec cette
ce qu'on essaye de faire au quotidien
merci beaucoup
Erwan alors vous vous êtes bénévole
accompagnant
avocat bénévole a compris
alors avocat d'ailleurs c'est c'est vrai
que moi j'ai j'ai complètement découvert
un univers parce que parce que en tant
qu'avocat et en droit des affaires je
travaille pas dans un milieu où prendre
soin et la bienveillance sont les
valeurs quotidiennes
et donc j'ai été j'ai été plongé dans
dans un milieu des soins palliatifs
qui a été un peu une révélation et pour
moi le sentiment qu'on avait
une tribune dernièrement pour dire que
c'était un trésor national mais de fait
de fête week on a un trésor national
pour le pays alors moi je suis venu à ça
d'abord par
peut la réflexion par mon histoire
personnelle sans aller dans les
Confessions Intimes je me réfère souvent
à ce qu'a dit François Bégaudeau dans
une conversation avec Sean rose où il
parle des enfants qui ont été marqués
par le compagnonage intime avec la mort
mais
la conscience de la mort et lui parle de
la de la pression ce concrète du trou je
crois que ça dit très clairement ce que
j'ai ce que j'ai ressenti à une certaine
à une certaine période et puis après
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer une une
infirmière quand j'avais 22 ans donc
c'était en 97 une infirmière en soins
palliatifs qui ne pouvait plus débriefer
tous les soirs à dîner avec sa famille
de ce qu'elle voyait
dans la journée ne pouvait pas trop
s'étendre sur les escarres et autres
délices des soins palliatifs et donc on
débriefait souvent toutes les semaines
on parlait on parlait ensemble pendant
45 minutes
ce qui m'a déjà informé quand même assez
tôt dans de l'existence des soins
palliatifs quand je vois aujourd'hui
qu'il y a encore des gens qui en
ignorent l'existence et qui est encore
des médecins qui ne savent pas ce que
c'est que les soins palliatifs voilà
c'était frappant je vous passe 25 ans
parce qu'on a pas le temps de faire les
25 ans
et après avoir donc voilà réfléchi lui
le livre de Marie de Hennezel entendu
Jean Leonetti et suivi l'évolution de la
législation accompagner quelques
associations en soins palliatifs à un
moment donné je me suis dit que c'était
bien gentil d'en parler qu'il fallait
peut-être aller y voir et donc il y a
cinq ans j'ai découvert les soins
palliatifs en allant dans le service de
Ségolène perruchio
je suis arrivé un matin un peu
un peu flippé j'avais peur que ça sent
mauvais j'avais peur d'entendre crier
partout j'avais peur de voir des visages
déformés
voilà je vais peur de pas tenir j'avais
peur de simplement de ne savoir rien
dire parce que souvent quand on se
retrouve face à des gens malades
on a des réponses idiotes qui vous
viennent qui vous viennent à l'esprit
comment ça va ça va pas et et puis le 8
avril ou plutôt exactement le 9 avril
lorsque la proposition de loi phalornit
a été votée dans son article premier
je me suis réveillé angoissée à l'idée
qu'un jour j'allais peut-être me
réveiller
avec une loi qui allait véritablement
être votée dans son intégralité et donc
c'est là que j'ai commencé à d'abord
demander à des amis s'il pensait que je
pouvais
écrire un livre sur le sujet si j'avais
une quelconque
titre à le faire et puis j'ai rencontré
pas mal de personnes dont trois sont
autour de cette table qui qui m'ont
expliqué pas mal de choses je suis allé
je suis allé à Gardanne dans
l'établissement la maison qui est un
établissement emblématique de des soins
palliatifs je vais aussi aller à jeune
Garnier j'ai écrit mon livre donc fin de
vie en république parce que pour moi
c'est important je pense que vraiment
nos valeurs de liberté d'égalité et de
fraternité sont véritablement mis en jeu
voire en péril dans ce dans ce débat et
puis j'ai peut-être fait les choses à
l'envers mais il se trouve que à force
de journée autour et à force d'observer
j'ai fini par me dire que je pouvais pas
continuer sans sans y aller puis quelque
part s'en rendre un peu de je vais
peut-être employer des termes
particuliers mais de la grâce que j'ai
trouvé en allant dans les en allant dans
les soins palliatifs
j'ai une vraie gratitude pour pour les
soignants parce que ils sont aussi pour
moi un vrai message d'espoir dans la
société une société qui parfois peut
nous déprimer bah quand je pense aux
gens qui font ce qu'ils font quand je
pense aux infirmières aux psychologues
aux aides-soignants qui se lèvent tous
les matins pour aller dans un lieu que
les autres Français préfèrent dans les
autres Français préfèrent ignorer
l'existence
passer leur journée là avoir des gens
qui décèdent
tous les jours quasiment selon la taille
de l'établissement
j'ai une vraie gratitude pour eux et
donc moi j'ai commencer il y a un an la
formation de bénévoles fort heureusement
une formation accompagnée par la
pratique sur le terrain donc je
j'accompagne chaque semaine
des patients c'est un rôle qui est quand
même assez particulier parce que
dans les soins palliatifs nous on arrive
les mains vides on a rien à faire on n'a
pas de relater
j'ai pas de soin à pratiquer j'ai juste
à offrir ma présence
et offrir sa présence c'est parfois
compliqué parce que faut s'ajuster en
permanence il y a des gens déjà il y a
des gens qui n'ont pas envie de me voir
donc il faut leur laisser la liberté de
me dire non pas maintenant ou votre tête
ne revient pas fallu le dise pas
clairement mais parfois ça se voit et
puis
et puis entendre
entendre des choses qui parfois vous
percutent je passais 50 minutes avec une
personne qui demandait à mourir
qui ne m'a jamais laissé la possibilité
de
l'esquisser la possibilité qui est une
porte de sortie on se retrouve face à
quelqu'un pendant 50 minutes qui vous
qui vous dit ça qui tient c'est pas une
expérience ordinaire j'ai rencontré des
gens qui qui vous disent un peu ce que
j'avais lu dans dans la morintime qui
vous disent vous disiez vous écriviez
c'est toutes ces choses que j'ai retenu
personne qui vous dit il a fallu que
j'en arrive là pour découvrir que la
bonté existe moi des personnes qui me
disent on n'est pas là c'est une maladie
c'est là qui m'a dit ça il y a quelques
temps et pourtant elle avait elle avait
sa ventilation
et était assez âgé sa ventilation et
donc pas très très bien parti et puis
elle me dit ah non c'est bien ici on est
aux petits oignons et bon voilà c'est
des choses je pense que les
les gens qui sont extérieurs au milieu
et alors moi j'ai peut-être le regard du
naïf du ravi de la crèche par rapport à
ceux qui ont une longue expérience mais
mais
les Français imaginent pas qu'on puisse
dans un établissement de soins
palliatifs qu'un patient puisse dire on
est aux petits oignons je me souviens
d'une femme a été bretonne donc elle
avait déjà une bonne qualité pour elle
je suis rentré dans sa chambre elle
était courbée en deux parce que c'était
quand même ça qui soulageait des
douleurs résiduelles au dos et qui dit
ah non on est bien ici bon c'est pas
l'endroit où on voudrait être enfin on
est bien ici et ça voilà c'est
ça vient
en opposition totale à ce que je ce que
je pensais trouver et quand vous disiez
que dans un établissement de son
palliatifs c'est calme effectivement
c'est voilà moi là où je suis c'est
c'est
pas que là où je suis partout je suis
passé
j'entends pas de hurlement je vois pas
de soignants courir et pourtant ils sont
réactifs c'est-à-dire que par rapport à
ce qu'on peut voir ailleurs moi je suis
toujours frappé de voir quand on est en
réunion de transmission
il y a la sonnette le numéro de la
chambre qui s'ouvre l'infirmière
responsable de la Chambre se lève elle y
va il y a quelqu'un qui qui
était hier je vois un monsieur par le
hublot qui était tordu dans son lit le
coup contre la barrière je me suis dit
qu'il allait finir par s'étrangler tout
seul je suis allé voir l'infirmière je
dis monsieur il est allé immédiatement
voilà tout ça je pense que vraiment les
Français le connaissent le connaissent
pas assez l'ignorant peut-être
totalement
j'ai une vraie angoisse que qu'une
modification législative vienne mettre
vraiment ça en péril parce que même la
clause de conscience ça suffira pas
parce que je pense que ça va dissuader
des gens d'aller en soins en PA ça va en
faire quitter les soins palliatifs et
que véritablement alors que tout le
monde est d'accord même les partisans
échevelés de l'euthanasie pour dire que
il faut il faut généralement les soins
palliatifs
j'ai la quasi certitude que si on
l'égalise le thanazisme on y mettra
peut-être pas un coup d'arrêt mais en
tout cas c'est clair que ce sera pas un
progrès
je vous remercie
oui vas-y Philippe merci beaucoup
François moi par rapport on est quoi ce
que vous avez dit parce que j'ai voté
l'article premier de la loi alors ni
mais plus en écho à ce que le docteur
pericchio a dit sur la mort provoquée
François le sait mes collègues le savent
mon domaine à moi c'était le domaine
militaire
et j'étais rapporteur
de la question des anciens combattants
et j'ai abordé ça sous le spectre de
notre humanisme parce que nous sommes
dans une formation humaniste et après
plusieurs rapports que j'ai fait nous
avons d'ailleurs dénommé l'Office
national des anciens combattants qui
s'appelle aujourd'hui l'Office national
des combattants parce que nous avons une
quatrième génération du feu
qui depuis le premier conflit en Europe
avec Yougoslavie sur les conflits au
Levant Daguet dans le BSS
Centrafrique
Mali et même en Amazonie nous luttons
contre trésorpilleurs nos combattants
ont un rapport constant avec la mort la
mort vu la mort reçu et la mort infligée
c'est ce qui nous a d'ailleurs permis en
2017 et en 2019 d'une manière renouvelée
augmentée de fournir un livret sur la
laïcité militaire qui est extrêmement
bien fait pour pouvoir expliquer à ce
jeune recrues nous intégrons comment ils
vont pouvoir
concilier leur rapport à la mort avec
leur activité
militaire guerrière mais vous le savez
c'est combattants reviennent avec un
syndrome extrêmement en créant eux très
fort très puissant très destructeur y
compris pour eux et la société qui est
le syndrome post-traumatique
et
c'est peut-être une réflexion c'est
peut-être à vous
dans vos dans vos réflexions
d'intégrer cette destruction qu'il y a
chez nos combattants de se retrouver
dans cette mort vue
parfois sur leurs camarades le binôme
tombe dans une explosion une balle
perdue ou bien ciblée et où la mort
infligée voilà c'est le témoignage que
je voulais vous apporter merci beaucoup
Philippe Alice comment
tu as été la cheville ouvrière de du
montage de cette rencontre
ton approche toi
je pense que pardon
tu as le droit
un peu ému juste parce que je pense que
effectivement enfin globalement on est
dans une société bon moi je suis élue
aussi comme ma collègue interne sur des
délégations de de solidarité de
proximité et en lien avec les
vulnérabilités sociales surtout assez
quotidiennement
pas trop en lien avec l'amour pour le
coup mais beaucoup en lien avec les
violences sociales et la solitude aussi
des personnes fragiles des personnes
âgées d'ailleurs souvent je dans ces
réflexions sur la fin de vie j'essaie
quand même de me former bien que n'étant
pas experte de ce sujet et je pense
souvent à
aux plans antisolites que François tu as
mis en place à Pau parce que j'établis
un lien entre la question de la solitude
la question de la mort la question de la
vulnérabilité et je me pose la question
dans le contexte actuel et je trouve
très réconfortant vos paroles à toutes
et tous parce qu'effectivement c'est
pour moi je pense il y a
en fait il y a toujours des trésors
d'humanité dans notre société qu'on ne
connaît pas assez qu'on méconnait qu'on
ne valorise pas suffisamment et
c'est pour moi sur ces trésors
d'humanité qu'on gagnerait à s'appuyer
davantage pour pour prendre mieux
meilleur soin de des personnes
vulnérables dans nos sociétés et
voilà du coup moi le le
la question que je me pose il y a un
point qu'on a peu évoqué jusqu'à
maintenant qui qui quand même est dans
le débat actuel sur la question de la
fin de vie et donc du message envoyé moi
je retiens parmi tout ce que vous disiez
l'enjeu du message qu'une loi sur la fin
de vie envers et aux personnes les plus
vulnérables et il se trouve que
par mes activités diverses et mon
parcours personnel je suis assez en lien
avec des personnes porteuses de handicap
en particulier en tout genre et je me
pose vraiment la question et on a eu
l'occasion d'en parler avec certaines
certains d'entre vous voilà du message
que on enverrait aux personnes les plus
vulnérables en disant bah si voilà
est-ce que ta vie est digne d'être vécue
quand tu es vulnérable quand tu es
dépendant quand tu es dépendant
quotidiennement
voilà il y a les enjeux de personnes en
situation de handicap en tout genre il y
a les questions qu'on n'a pas évoqué
jusqu'à maintenant mais de personnes
malades psychiques ou en vulnérabilité
psychique et donc je pense enfin comme
vous l'avez évoqué les uns et les autres
on est frappé de voir à l'occasion de se
débat à quel point la culture palliative
est méconnue à quel point on ne parle
pas de la mort dans nos sociétés à quel
point par exemple quand il y a des
obsèques il y a quasiment plus d'enfants
dans les églises ou dans les lieux
d'obsèques parce que on veut pas où on
veut disons ne pas trop exposer nos
enfants à la mort hors la mort
partie de la vie et donc d'un point de
vue vraiment politique enfin de notre
place de mouvement politique moi je le
sentiment
d'abord je pense que ce débat le mérite
de parler d'un sujet dont jusqu'à
présent on parlait assez peu en réalité
et je me demande comment
alors
tu vois pas loin que dans quel modalité
et je suis pas législateur donc je tiens
un tout petit peu un pas de côté de ça
en revanche je me demande comment nous
politique mouvement politique on peut
aussi
accompagner le développement de cette
culture palliative et comme vous le
disiez monsieur Leonetti tout à l'heure
sur voilà rappeler aussi ce qui fonde ce
qu'ils font notre société ce qu'ils font
de notre humanité ce qu'ils font de
voilà
comment on se retrouve dans le regard de
l'autre et parce que finalement on est
quand même des êtres de relation et le
et l'autonomie pour moi à des limites
au sens de on peut évidemment c'est
important l'autonomie mais l'autonomie
dans une relation vécue avec un regard
échangé avec voilà et et j'ai
l'impression que dans ce débat pour une
partie des personnes qui qui tiennent
une une position cette question de
l'interaction
et de la solidarité et parfois passer au
second plan voilà ce que m'inspire
alors j'aurais tendance à dire que
j'étais un peu
programmée pour être très favorable
à l'euthanasie à l'aide active à mourir
et puis lorsque la
PPL falorgny est arrivée à l'Assemblée
je me suis posé quelques heures et j'ai
commencé à réfléchir sur chacun des
aspects je me suis posé beaucoup de
questions et je me suis dit qu'en fait
tout ça faisait poser beaucoup plus de
questions
que en tout cas ne m'apporter de réponse
à titre personnel et puis au cours de la
campagne pendant les législatives de
juin la seule chose la chose dont on m'a
le plus parlé je dirais pas la seule
chose mais la chose dont on a le plus
parlé c'était de l'aide active à mourir
alors depuis lors j'essaye de réfléchir
et en fait moi il y a je suis pas une
scientifique je ne suis pas une mais un
médecin ce qui me pose profondément
question et vous l'avez ce qui s'est
madame
et Alice également c'est
la place
Corée les plus vulnérables et les plus
âgés dans notre société à partir du
moment où ça deviendrait une solution et
j'entends souvent les gens dire ça ne
t'enlève rien comme droit et ça en donne
aux autres et je crois que
fondamentalement sur cette question ça
n'est pas une question individuelle
c'est une question collective c'est une
question de société alors je me pose
beaucoup de questions et ça me je suis
très très honoré que Alice et François
Bayrou nous a permis mes permis de vous
entendre aujourd'hui parce que c'est
voilà c'est extrêmement précieux merci
beaucoup
merci à toi
moi j'ai eu la chance une chance enfin
la chance inouïe de naître dans une
famille extraordinaire qui m'a appris
toute petite à envisager la mort voilà
la morphe faisait partie de la vie et ce
qui m'a permis d'affronter
la mort de mes proches évidemment
où la mort de personne qui ne m'était
pas proches mais voilà et par la même
occasion de se poser quand même des
questions métaphysiques qui font en font
notre existence et vous l'avez
d'ailleurs
remarquablement dit et formulé et je me
suis dit en quand j'ai eu mes enfants on
s'est dit avec mon mari qu'on ferait
tout ce qui était en notre pouvoir pour
que justement cette mort fasse partie de
la vie aussi
et tu disais Alice qu'aujourd'hui on ne
voit plus d'enfants dans dans les
inhumations et moi j'ai fait ça j'ai
emmené mes enfants dans les inhumations
ce qui a d'ailleurs provoqué parfois
quelques remous mais j'y tenais parce
que ils étaient aussi une vie au moment
de la mort et souvent on me l'a dit
d'ailleurs merci d'avoir
en étant enfant et puis parce que du
coup s'ils sont confrontés et je me
souviens que le jour de l'enterrement de
leur arrière-grand-mère on était un jour
du mois de mars devant lequel vous
familial
d'inhumation a lieu etc et donc il ne
restait plus de cette génération là que
la sœur de cette arrière-grand-mère donc
leur arrière grande tente à l'époque je
l'avais pas six enfants mais cinq la
dernière était pas né encore et donc une
giboulée de mars on monte à toute
vitesse dans la voiture la petite
dernière qui à ce moment là avait trois
ans monte voilà un silence se fait et la
petite dernière de sa petite voix nous
dit mais alors maintenant
il ne reste plus que ton Nadine et elle
va mourir parce qu'elle est vieille elle
aussi et les quatre autres se retournent
et lui disent d'un seul cœur mais tu
sais de toute façon on va tous mourir et
je me suis dit qu'au fond il s'était
voilà on avait peut-être réussi quelque
chose et du coup en fait ce que vous
vous échangez là de votre expérience de
votre pratique de votre parcours
avec des mots enfin sur des questions
qui sont très philosophiques à la fois
pertinent mais ceci est tellement aussi
pose la question de cette éducation
faut-il que on est une éducation à la
mort donc voilà voyez une éducation à la
mort je sais pas comment le dire
autrement
idéalement bien sûr par la famille ça me
paraît le premier lieu pour ça mais si
ce n'est pas la famille ce qu'on a pas
tous la chance de vivre dans des
familles qui ont qui se sont interrogés
sur ces questions là
où peut-on le faire et ça peut être nos
responsabilités aussi on fait du soutien
à la parentalité quand on est élu local
on passe notre temps à ça à penser des
politiques publiques envers les familles
et donc du soutien la parentalité donc
est-ce que ça il faut qu'on qu'on pense
qu'on l'imagine comment on peut le faire
avec quels outils
voilà donc c'est une question pour moi
c'est une autre des questions c'est
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on forme les
étudiants en médecine j'ai un fils
étudiant médecine je vois bien le
cette suprématie qui démarre très tôt en
fait dès qu'ils ont passé le concours la
remise du stéthoscope la manière dont le
dont l'ordre des médecins met la main je
suis désolé de parler dans ces termes-là
mais la main sur ses étudiants
le peu de temps qu'ils ont à consacrer à
ces questions quelles sont les freins
pour former au fond alors que dès qu'on
vous entend les choses sont tellement
évidentes en fait tellement voilà ça
semble tellement évident finalement
c'est pas si difficile de réfléchir à ça
et c'est surtout une Fame semble-t-il
dans ce que vous dites c'est finalement
une expérience humaine en fait c'est une
expertise en humanité que vous
développez qu'est-ce pourquoi est-ce
qu'on n'arrive pas à faire ça est-ce que
d'ailleurs vous parliez de la peur des
médecins est-ce qu'il y a une question
de de
judiciarisation qui est certainement
enfin j'imagine voilà cette peur elle
est liée aussi au procès qu'on pourrait
faire à la confrontation des questions
des familles etc et puis monsieur
Leonetti me disait tout à l'heure on
vous écoutant mais ce que vous avez vécu
dans l'hémicycle avec cette capacité à
fonder quelque chose de fort et d'utile
à finalement construire un monde par
cette loi un monde plus juste et plus
fraternel avec l'expression de cette
option préférentielle pour les plus
vulnérables est-ce que vous pensez que
aujourd'hui c'est encore possible dans
l'hémicycle alors aujourd'hui pas au
sens compte tenu du contexte mais au
fond comment est-ce qu'on en arrive
comment on en est arrivé là et je veux
dire après peut-être
essayons de pas de pas faire dériver le
débat parce qu'on a pas beaucoup de
temps en fait ça fait déjà plus d'une
heure qu'on est ensemble
Marie
oui merci
moi je suis comme vous j'ai la chance
d'avoir grandi dans une famille où on
parlait de la mort et peut-être parce
que je suis fille de gynécologue
obstétricien qui m'a toujours dit que
quand on donne naissance à un enfant on
donne d'abord naissance à un être humain
qui va mourir et j'ai toujours été élevé
dans cette dans cette voilà dans
l'absence de tabou de la mort j'ai été
amené à travailler sur ces questions là
en tant que juriste
et
ce qui m'a ce qui m'a frappé c'est que
durant ça fait maintenant 25 ans que je
travaille sur les sujets de fin de vie
en tant que juriste et ça fait 25 ans
qu'on dit que les soins palliatifs ne
sont pas suffisamment développés à
l'hôpital qu'on ne parle pas de la mort
que c'est toujours un tabou que la
formation des médecins n'a pas changé et
que à part des QCM mon premier année on
leur parle pas de la fin de vie
et tout ça n'a pas évolué et moi je
m'interroge sur la réaction de notre
société qui fasse à un échec en fait
énorme des politiques de santé qui n'ont
pas réussi à mettre en oeuvre les soins
palliatifs
avec une égalité d'accès au sans
palliatifs et j'ai des expériences
récentes qui prouvent que tout le monde
n'a pas la chance d'avoir été soigné par
des médecins durant leur fin de vie par
des médecins comme vous et c'est bien
dommage et la seule réponse qu'on
pourrait apporter à ces patients c'est
une capitulation
qui serait et bien nous n'arrivons pas à
mettre en place un droit à l'accès aux
soins palliatifs pour tous nous
n'arrivons pas à accompagner dignement
les personnes en fin de vie nous
n'arrivons pas à aider des personnes qui
veulent se suicider à avoir envie de
vivre nous n'arrivons pas à aider les
personnes vulnérables nous n'arrivons
pas à aider les personnes dépendantes à
trouver du sens à leur vie et bien
proposons leur
de les aider à mettre fin à leurs jours
voilà on nous présente ça comme un
progrès mais pour moi
il y a une vraie question qu'est-ce que
le progrès et est-ce que c'est un
progrès qu'une société fasse ça
et puis ensuite je dirais pour conclure
parce que je vous remercie déjà de
m'avoir donné la parole
ce qui m'a frappé quand j'ai travaillé à
la PHP
une expérience passionnante avec des
gens passionnants qui osaient parler de
la mort et on avait une approche
pluridisciplinaire avec des juristes des
soignants des médecins des représentants
des usagers enfin des gens formidables
on a beaucoup travaillé sur ces
questions là et ce qui nous a frappé
c'est que les contentieux qui nous
étaient remontés c'était proprement
l'inverse que des demandes à mourir
puisque c'était des patients et des
familles qui refusaient l'arrêt des
traitements et le juge est entré à
l'hôpital
par cette porte non pas parce qu'on
demandait
à mettre fin à la vie et qu'on
reprochait au médecin de ne pas mettre
fin à la vie mais parce qu'on reprochait
au médecin de dire ça suffit
maintenant c'est de l'acharnement
thérapeutique il faut arrêter et ça je
crois que c'est très simple
la majorité des gens veulent vivre
jusqu'au bout
le désir de survie il est impressionnant
quand on quand on le voit quand on le
rencontre
et donc voilà déjà mille merci pour tout
ce que vous nous avez raconté et je
crois qu'il y a une vraie question de
savoir qu'est-ce que le progrès dans
notre société et qu'est-ce que quels
sont les issues que l'on doit proposer à
ces personnes là
bon on a fini le tour de enfin le
premier ce tour de table là pas le
premier mais le deuxième
pour qu'on soit à égalité moi je vous
raconte
quelques en quelques phrases
moi je viens de l'autre monde
je viens d'un monde qui était
probablement
inchangé depuis des siècles
puisque
non seulement la mort faisait partie de
la vie
mais la mort le la prise en charge de la
mort était une obligation civique
la société des villages Béarnais quand
j'étais enfant et pas seulement enfant
mais déjà adulte jeune adulte il y avait
pas de pompes funèbres
le la société de ces villages est
effondrée sur ce qu'on appelle voisinage
le devoir de voisinage médias
et le BZ c'était
chaque famille avec quatre voisins
parce qu'il y avait quatre poignées au
cercueil
et on voisiné alors ça faisait plein
d'obligations vous avez des invités au
fait au baptême au Pelleport
souvent quand ils étaient nombreux ils
mangés plus que enfin bon
c'était c'était et
j'ai fait ça avec les mains qui sont là
moi j'ai enseveli
aider à la toilette ce n'est pas
beaucoup ça
c'était souvent les femmes qui faisaient
ça
mais et on prenait en charge la ferme
pendant le temps où on s'occupait des
défunts elle fait ça puis j'ai rencontré
la mort assez tôt comme plusieurs
d'entre vous le savent
et c'est vrai que ça a totalement
disparu le l'institution des pompes
funèbres a totalement coupé si je veux
dire ce lien là
et puis évidemment la vie fait qu'on
rencontre qu'on rencontre la mort plus
souvent
j'ai été depuis très longtemps sensible
à ce sujet je dis à Jean j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi à son à sa loi à son
intervention à sa réflexion
et c'est en pleine conscience que j'ai
que j'ai voté pour pour ton texte
et
comme tu as eu la gentillesse de le
rappeler j'ai construit à pose un plan
anti solitude il prend beaucoup en
charge des choses comme ça pas seulement
l'enfant aussi
l'enfance le handicap
l'adolescence qui est un monde
bon qu'on souhaiterait à personne parce
que mais on en parle jamais
je fais une incidence je suis très très
certaine que si dans chacune des classes
des psychologues venaient pour raconter
ce qu'est l'adolescence et le mal-être
que très souvent ça suscite on aurait
moins de suicides d'enfants on aurait
peut-être moins de harcèlement bon c'est
pas pris en charge du tout
et donc cette question là elle va elle
va débouler dans le débat public et
pour ma part je ferai en sorte que le
l'expression des consciences de ceux qui
sont engagés chez nous puissent
s'exprimer à plein sans être entraîné de
l'extérieur en tout cas on va faire ça
je voudrais aborder
deux autres sujets les deux derniers
sujets premier sujet
Jean et vous tous qui êtes soignants
quel est l'état de la situation
quelle est la part
de
cette vocation médicale qui est bien
exercée
on parle des équipes mobiles combien de
départements vous m'avez dit ça clair
combien de départements n'ont pas
d'équipe mobile ou de moins en moins
combien ça coûterait
je suis très frappé par le nombre de
patients j'ai encore eu un exemple tout
à fait récent et proche
qui d'abord disent je veux mourir et
après ils veulent pas qu'on interrompre
le traitement
se mettent en colère parce que on leur
dit qu'on interrompt le traitement c'est
vous clair qui m'avez dit que dans toute
votre carrière sur les
milliers 18000 je crois que vous m'avez
dit 12000 personnes que vous avez
accompagné il y en a que trois qui qui
ont exprimé qui ont persisté
bon c'est extrêmement intéressant
et combien ça coûterait Jean
si on voulait mettre à niveau la
médecine palliative ou les soins
palliatifs en France
alors qu'est-ce qui
à la fois très cher et pas cher
très cher si on veut développer des
unités de sous le contrôle de Claire et
de vous tous l'unité de soins palliatifs
on va pas tous y mourir et il faut pas
tout s'y mourir on doit y admettre que
des situations
complexes on va dire simple pour faire
simple donc en réalité c'est la
développement d'une culture palliative
si je suis objectif c'est mieux qu'avant
c'est mieux qu'avant parce que même si
les étudiants ont pas une formation à la
hauteur de la mort et de la souffrance
que les malades ressentent
bien sûr moi je suis vieux donc
je parle d'un temps très ancien mais
il y avait l'abandon ou le cocktail
lytique
en pratique et dans les maladies qu'on
apprenait il ne mourraient jamais ils ne
souffrait pas ou plus exactement la
souffrance est un symptôme qui nous
permet de faire un diagnostic mais
absolument pas quelque chose qu'il
fallait prendre en compte et donc dans
le cahier thérapeutique qui suivait pour
la préparation au concours il y avait la
chimiothérapie la radiothérapie pour
parler des cancers mais il y avait
jamais les antalgiques et
l'accompagnement parlait pas la famille
on annonce pas donc je trouve que c'est
mieux et honnêtement je trouve que la
génération qui monte est une génération
ouverte
elle est moins dans la médecine
triomphante moins dans J'ai greffé un
coeur je m'appelle Barnard et regardez
comme je suis beau et effectivement il
attire la caméra celui qui dit ça j'ai
refait le pouce
voilà il arrive et il dit quelque chose
et l'autre il ne fait que rien puisque
il n'empêche pas la mort il ne fait que
la compagnie donc il y a un problème de
prestige il y a pas de PUPH et quand une
université reçoit des moyens elle les ou
à l'hôpital il les attributs à ce qui
lui paraît le plus urgent c'est à dire
ce qui est le plus violent c'est à dire
les urgences la Real le bloc opératoire
c'est c'est l'obsession habituelle j'ai
revu Jean-François Matt et à l'Académie
de médecine l'autre jour et il me disait
qu'il était il avait quand il était
isolé il avait donné une enveloppe
à l'Assistance Publique des Hôpitaux de
Marseille pour les soins palliatifs
quelque temps après il rencontre le
directeur et lui dit alors c'est un truc
je vous avoue monsieur le ministre j'ai
pas mis là parce que j'avais tellement
de besoins à un chirurgie que j'ai mis
de l'argent sur donc c'est c'est
tout ce qui reste à faire quand il y a
plus rien à faire et c'est tout ce qui
reste des budgets quand on a tout bouffé
ailleurs voilà donc
c'est une situation qui malheureusement
une situation prestige voilà c'est
Prométhée Prométhée triomphant la
médecine française une médecine très
solidaire
par rapport aux États-Unis mais aussi
triomphante des États-Unis on veut
l'exploit voilà donc on veut la
performance c'est pas une mauvaise chose
d'ailleurs dans certains domaines de
vouloir la performance exploit sauf que
c'est une éducation voilà donc si on
développait les soins palliatifs le
danger c'est que les gens croient savoir
c'est le plus gros danger de la vie
c'est celui-là c'est pas quand on en a
pas mal je te le confirme quand on sait
pas on sait qu'on sait pas quand on
croit qu'on sait les conséquent c'est
c'est là que la catastrophe arrive et en
médecine elle arrive assez vite or la
plupart des médecins d'une certaine
génération ont ils savent voilà ils
savent gérer la mort parce qu'ils ont
encore le cocktail liquide dans la tête
et au fond pour pour eux c'est assez
simple voilà alors que c'est devenu le
médecine complexe professionnelle
technique
qui tient compte des dosages des des
réactions enfin qui connaît la
pharmacologie donc
la première des choses ça serait la
formation continue c'est pas très cher
la formation continue en compte n'est-il
l'imposer et puis il y a des CHU qui ont
pas d'humidité de soins palliatif on
donne des agréments aujourd'hui pour
fonctionner suffirait de dire
directement tu es gentil mais voilà si
tu veux l'agrément pour ton hôpital il y
a des lits des unités sur un palliatifs
ou des lits identifier de ce Palestine
et du personnel formé donc on a dans un
modèle français la capacité
pas de tout réformer dans la médecine
qui mérite effectivement une réforme
profonde en tout cas cette capacité de
d'enclencher quelque chose combien ça
coûte
ça coûte ça coûte mais au fond je dirais
que si on développe plus la culture
palliative que des unités qu'on inaugure
en coupant des rubans on va on peut
aller assez vite et pas trop cher et nos
étudiants paradoxalement moi je les vois
les internes qui passent en soins
palliatifs ils sont ils sont attirés par
l'esprits relatif voilà et là aussi la
génération ancienne qui était cette
génération du triomphe nous on choisit
ces cardio réachirurgie voilà
ce serait pas relatif ça existait même
pas mais la gérontologie même pas en
rêve veut dire que on va pas se voyait
les vieux on veut triompher on veut
sauver des vies voilà
et j'ai vu récemment le ministre qu'elle
a sauvé quelques-unes et qui disait avec
beaucoup d'humidité et d'intelligence
qu'en fait il avait plutôt empêché la
mort que sauver des vies
parce que la finitude elle est là et un
moment donné le médecin même le plus
triomphant il se heurte au mur de la
mort pour lui et pour ses patients et il
faut pas non plus ça c'est un autre
culture que la mort soit un échec voilà
moi pendant des années j'ai considéré
que les mortalités de mon service si
elle augmentait c'était un échec voilà
être performant voilà donc je
gentiment mais je tyrannisais un peu
tout le monde en disant aucune vie doit
être perdue c'est pas une mauvaise idée
ça veut dire quand on est dans un
service de cardio voudrait mais je veux
dire ce culture là elle est quand même
diffusée un peu partout donc il me
semble
que c'est un préalable à tout
imaginons et ça a été dit intelligemment
imaginons confresse une loi
et qu'on dise ben voilà on vous fait une
loi vous avez le droit de de
en adéquation vous avez le droit de
demander la mort et de l'obtenir
et puis je sais que si je vais en soins
palliatif je vais diviser par 5 la
demande de mort ça veut dire que non
seulement je fais pas un travail de
fraternité mais je vais pas un travail
d'égalité parce que le citoyen n'est pas
égal devant la mort et donc là ça serait
terrible de faire une une loi par défaut
je crois que que c'est une évidence
c'est ça il y a pas beaucoup de choses
dans lequel on est certain il est de la
mort on change d'avis et on est torturé
par des désirs de mort et des désirs de
vie le président disait c'est le combat
des roses et de Thanatos c'est vrai et
on a envie celui qui me reconnaît on a
envie qui meurt vite
parce que au moins il souffre pas et je
ne souffre pas de le voir souffrir et en
même temps j'ai envie de le garder
vous avez le temps je vais vous
raconterai une histoire du Talmud qui
est magnifique
oui
alors je vais te raconter l'Assemblée
nationale ce qui me vaut de Rahim Corsia
le titre de rabbin dans les considère
que je suis donc tu as un vieux rabbin
qui meurt et enfin il meurt le terme est
mal choisi il est pas mort puisqu'il est
vivant parce que c'est quand même ça
l'important mais il va mourir et donc il
est dans cette zone grise d'attente et
donc le Talmud raconte que les rabbins
d'en bas veulent pas le perdre parce
qu'il a été tellement sain et elle parle
telle sagesse qui prit très fort pour
qu'il reste il prit bien sûr l'Éternel
pour qu'il reste et puis au ciel ils
sont plus sages et ils disent bon bah ça
va il a vécu sa vie charnelle maintenant
il faut qu'il ait la béatitude auprès de
l'Éternel et les anges au prix pour
qu'enfin l'âme du rabbin monte et les
prières sont agonisent
et donc
une servante et c'est intéressant que ce
soit une femme et une servante dans le
telmut elle rentre et l'interpelle
l'éternel elle le dit mais tu nous
laisses bien mais tu laisses pas en
train de souffrir ou tu le prends mais
tu fais pas cette zone entre deux parce
que c'est ça qui est
l'agonie il a pris agonique qui est une
souffrance pour dire que chacun rêve de
la mort subite pendant son sommeil à 110
ans quoi voilà en pleine forme donc et
ça il répond pas à l'Éternel voilà bon
chacun aura une interprétation
particulière et à ce moment-là elle
prend une cruche et elle brise la cruche
et en brisant la cruche les Robins qui
prient en bas qui sont des humains
l'entendent et s'arrêtent un instant de
prier et l'âme du rabbin peut monter au
ciel
ça montre bien l'antagonisme qui entre
ses désirs de mort et ses désirs de vie
au du malade lui-même mais oh de
l'entourage du malade et de l'entourage
qu'il aime c'est désirs de mort de vie
des médecins la mort du malade ça
soulage elle permet de partir sur un
autre malade surtout dans la médecine
que j'ai pratiqué moi et pas besoin
palliatif et puis ça montre ça montre
que de temps en temps et ben tout ce qui
est tout ce qui est humainement
raisonnable et pas de techniquement
souhaitable et que donc un moment donné
il faut savoir briser la cruche et le
servant c'est le soignant c'est la
société qui dit là on arrête parce que
[Musique]
il le faisait assez vite et assez mal
parce que on soulageait pas la
souffrance mais il y avait cette cette
mort familiale et familière qui
disparaît et qui n'est pas hospitalière
à l'hôpital donc on meurt avec des types
en blanc qui ont des masques et donc on
regarde que les regards c'est c'est un
des éléments de de la déconnexion de de
la mort avec la société la vie
tout ça est formidable clair un petit
bilan chiffré que qu'est-ce que
les lois en terme de la loi actuelle
est-ce qu'elle est appliquée dans quelle
proportion
et est-ce qu'on pourrait se faire une
idée de ce que représenterait une
application une bonne application de la
loi en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
là où elle est appliquée ça fonctionne
donc ça on a et quand même par rapport à
tout ce qui a été dit quand on se
regarde en arrière maintenant moi je
c'est l'avantage de vieillir c'est quand
on regarde en arrière on voit d'où on
vient il y a quand même beaucoup qui a
été fait il faudrait pas donner
l'impression que ça n'a pas bougé c'est
quand même impressionnant enfin moi je
vois là où je suis là où j'ai commencé
c'était zéro et ben voilà on est plus à
zéro il y a encore beaucoup quand on
regarde en avant il y a encore beaucoup
à faire mais quand même beaucoup a été
fait et en termes de coût alors le
chiffrage qui est quand même vraiment
très compliqué il dit autour de 750
millions on arriverait à accompagner
correctement ce qui est beaucoup et en
même temps pas gigantesque mais surtout
c'est que c'est une réorientation c'est
pas forcément des de l'argent nouveau
non il y a besoin c'est que si on fait
pas la 14e ligne de chimiothérapie de
molécules onéreuses qui coûte 7000 euros
l'ampoule et dont on sait que le gain de
survie va être de 12 jours dans des
conditions difficiles si la culture
collective elle dit que c'est plus
valorisant pour un établissement que si
on a fait plus de 50% de chimiothérapie
dans le dernier mois de vie on aura un
malus mais que si on a accompagné plus
de 50% des patients qui décèdent on aura
un bonus alors il faut bien sûr je le
dis de manière un peu caricaturale mais
qu'en tout cas si on arrive à inciter
avoir une politique qui incite à de
bonnes pratiques qu'on a défini
collectivement c'est pas forcément
d'argent nouveau mais il y a besoin
c'est juste de réorienter parfois
certains flux financiers actuellement
c'est plus rentable pour un
établissement de faire une 14ème ligne
de chimiothérapie et
l'accompagnement n'est absolument pas
valorisé et les infirmières qui partent
actuellement de l'hôpital elles partent
parce que ça n'a pas de sens pour elle
ce qu'on leur demande et et l'impression
de devenir maltraitante et là aussi si
on remet du sens dans ce qui est fait si
on remet de l'accompagnement on va
garder des professionnels qui qui ont
choisi ces métiers là on a tous choisi
ces métiers là vous l'avez entendu parce
qu'on a envie de d'être utile parce que
ça rend heureux d'être utile et je crois
que pour ses soignants c'est la même
chose et donc c'est vraiment une
question de de penser collective alors
pour vous donner trois petites pistes de
réflexion qui ont sur lesquelles on a
mis en oeuvre sur la question de la de
la propriété collective aussi de cet
accompagnement de la mort on a un
programme pour les jeunes qui s'appelle
Nabilla mort on en parle qui a un site
dans toutes les classes il y a un enfant
orphelin en moyenne et pour pouvoir
parler de la mort pour aider les
enseignants à parler de la mort et dès
les parents il y a un site qui est super
bien fait qui donne plein d'outils pour
parler de la mort avec des enfants selon
l'âge mais on peut parler de la mort à
tous les âges c'est le rôle de la
famille c'est le rôle de l'école c'est
le rôle de la société et donc voilà on
peut accompagner ça
on a récupéré un programme qui le
dernier secours qui a un programme
allemand le l'idée c'est la tête pareil
qu'on fait une formation au premier
secours qui s'appelle first aide une
journée pour tout le monde pour former
au premier secours une journée de
sensibilisation pour le grand public à
la question de la compagnement
l'accompagnement c'est pas une affaire
que de soignant c'est une affaire de
nous tous et en une journée des des
petites notions de base à la fois
pratique et théoriques et ça rencontre
un succès qui nous dépasse complètement
c'est à dire que c'est très compliqué
pour nous de répondre aux demandes des
entreprises des mairies voilà une
journée pour le grand public il y a 20
pays qui font ça en Europe les Allemands
ils forment les lycéens au dernier
secours avec l'idée que l'accompagnement
c'est pour tout le monde et puis la
troisième chose c'est une petite
expérience plus petite je dis à Marie
j'ai participé cette année la fac de
Montpellier la fac de médecine met en
place pour les étudiants de deuxième
année de médecine qui font un stage
infirmier un groupe d'analyses de
pratiques je me retrouve avec la psycho
de notre équipe avec un de 25 étudiants
qui ont fait deux jours de stage je me
dis mais qu'est-ce qu'on fout là
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont avoir à nous dire
ils sont 25 c'est énorme pour un groupe
de parole ils ont fait deux jours de
stage en deux heures de temps ils
avaient tout repéré la question de la
distance la question de la mort est-ce
que je suis fait pour ça et j'ai vu des
médecins qui disaient des trucs
incroyables enfin en deux et si on les
prend tout petit ces étudiants et qu'on
les accompagne ils sont hyper ouverts et
hyper intéressés les internautes qui
passent chez nous sont des jeunes
passionnants et super bon bien meilleur
que ce qu'on était au même âge et donc
moi je trouve qu'il y a plein d'espoir
et plein de choses à faire
oui
je voulais dire que quand on parle de
moyens pour les autres palliatifs c'est
pas seulement pour les soins palliatifs
c'est pour les soins c'est à dire que
quand vous avez une aide-soignante dans
une EHPAD pour 80 malades même si votre
médecin est formé on pourra pas faire du
de l'accompagnement correct donc en
effet peut-être qu'il faut des moyens
importants parce que des aidants il y en
a plus les aidants à domicile on en
trouve pas là je vous dis sur un
bourgogne les gens ne peuvent pas
rentrer chez eux parce qu'il y a
personne pour leur faire la toilette
et ça il faut en tenir compte et c'est
probablement des réorientations de flux
parce que en effet les films coûte cher
petite anecdote j'étais dans un lame lit
d'accueil médicalisé ou ce sont des sans
papiers très malades il se trouve que
j'ai eu 50% de mortalité j'ai été viré
parce qu'il valait beaucoup mieux les
envoyer à l'hôpital
que les accompagner sur place les
accompagner sur place ça coûtait quand
même beaucoup moins cher que les envoyer
à l'hôpital vous avez les urgences le
marché des trucs et oui finalement ils
sont morts quand même les autres dans
les autres lames en fait c'est les mêmes
malades mais aussi mais il y aura à
l'hôpital parce que j'essaie de dire
c'est que dans les EHPAD c'est pareil on
en voit mourir à l'hôpital ça coûte très
cher
on pourrait à la place de ça payer les
aides soignantes et ça c'est quand même
une réorientation complètement des soins
en privilégiant ces soins là qui sont
des soins de base et c'est pas seulement
les soins palliatifs j'insiste parce que
en équipe mobile on peut faire ce qu'on
veut si le personnel a pas le temps il a
pas le temps
je vous dis faire 80 sur toilettes dans
la journée vous ferez jamais bien
soit je peux dire
on doit s'en occuper de tous et
mais la loi est quand même elle a un
caractère universel et symbolique
on part sur
si on est en Belgique 2% de la
population qui demande et obtient la
mort
elle a 98 qui demande rien même en
Belgique
ou le panel est complet euthanasie
suicide insister
là je les psychiatres les psychiatriques
etc
donc en beurre tous il y a 98% des gens
dont il faut s'occuper mais élargissons
encore
je rebondis ce que vous dites qui me
paraît tout à fait pertinent il y a pas
la mort c'est pas les 10 derniers jours
c'est pas les trois dernières semaines
la mort c'est la vulnérabilité d'un
problème de d'une population qui
vieillit d'une population qui survit et
qui quelquefois est handicapé en fait
c'est une loi de vulnérabilité donc à ce
moment là
du plus législateur mais
comment regarder une loi qui va essayer
de d'être l'arbre qui cache la forêt
d'un problème de société majeur
problème de société majeure si on enlève
les 20% des actes chirurgicaux inutiles
pratiqués en France 20%
c'est pas rien
ça montre que la chimiothérapie de trop
ça montre qu'il faut changer de
paradigme et les soins palliatifs il
nous apprennent que le médecin est pas
omnip béton beau temps que c'est une
équipe qui peut travailler et que on
peut diffuser le Caire et le tuyau en
même temps le traitement et le soin
donc c'est une révolution je dirais
culturel qu'il faut faire mais si on
part d'une d'un texte législatif qui
englobe l'ensemble et qu'on descend
après éventuellement sur et il reste
là-bas une demande de mort en soins
palliatifs trois pendant 18 ans ou sur
12000 patients c'est pas illégitime mais
d'abord on s'occupe de l'ensemble du
problème plutôt que de penser que il y a
que ce problème là alors ce problème là
il est médiatique et des douloureux il
est symbolique il est caricature parce
qu'on dit c'est les conservateurs contre
les progressistes c'est les religieux
contre laïques c'est les rouges contre
les Bleus etc mais c'est pas ça le vrai
problème le vrai problème c'est que un
peu comme le tenazi ou l'acharnement
thérapeutique ça permet de masquer si je
règle le problème de du suicide assisté
j'ai réglé le problème
j'ai rien réglé j'ai pas le régler le
problème du tragique de la vie de la
finitude de la dépendance d'une société
qui qui parle en permanence de la force
de la performance de de la Genèse etc et
qui te dit et qui te passe le message si
tu es pas comme ça j'ai quand même le
mot dignité est employé est-ce que
vraiment tu es pas un poids et dans la
demande de mort que j'ai connu moi
l'époque
souvent il y avait je pèse sur ma
famille vous voyez pas ma fille elle a
plus de vie où je pèse sur la société
avec ce que je coûte arrêtons on peut
dire tout le monde est utile le plus
vulnérable le le Moran le mendiant il
vaut voilà et si on dit tu vaux moins et
que tu peux partir et ça serait même
bien que tu partes si tu étais digne
voilà puisque moi je vais mourir
dignement parce que je vais me donner la
mort toi tu es pas digne toi bon tu peux
choisir
tu as les soins palliatifs
je pense que il y a un enjeu de société
un vrai enjeu de civilisation même tu
disais qu'est-ce qu'on porte comme
valeur dans la France elle porte trop de
choses que la valeur uniquement de la
performance je vais pas être gentille
mais anglo-saxonne quoi je veux dire
Marie est-ce que je peux juste rebondir
Jean
à partir de ce que j'entends depuis 15
ans j'ai des personnes de 80 à 100 ans
qui avec qui j'aborde la question de la
mort parce que dans ce parcours
l'aventure de vieillir il y a un atelier
sur la mort où chacun est invité à
parler de ce qu'est la mort pour lui de
et les gens l'ont besoin ils le
réclament et aussi de leur peur et de et
alors ce que j'entends c'est que ces
deux choses d'une part mourir dans la
dignité c'est mourir dans son lit pas à
l'hôpital pas de transfert à l'hôpital
c'est évidemment sans souffrir sans être
prolongé sans être forcé à s'alimenter
je sais pas si vous avez vu que j'ai
fait une tribune dans Le Monde sur le
respect du refus de s'alimenter des
personnes très âgées qui ont juste envie
de glisser doucement dans la mort
mais ce n'est pas un syndrome ce n'est
pas le
syndrome de glissement parce qu'il y a
pas de connotation de de détresse de les
gens sont sereins ils sont arrivés à la
fin de leur vie ils ont juste envie
qu'on les laisse tranquille de glisser
doucement en entendant la vie les gens
qui viennent leur parler les toucher
enfin ils veulent se sentir voilà ce
cocon de vie autour et glissé dans la
mort ça c'est leur souhait et leur
crainte ils me l'ont ils me le disent
tous leurs craintes avec là depuis que
qu'on parle de ça ce projet de loi sur
le suicide assisté ou l'euthanasie l'art
crainte c'est qu'un jour il y a une
injonction de mort c'est à dire qu'on
leur dise qu'on leur fasse comprendre
que les
héritiers attendent que il coûte cher à
la société que on sait que les six
derniers mois de la vie c'est quand même
ce qui sans doute les moi qui coûte le
plus cher donc une injonction de mort
qu'on les que finalement on leur demande
de
au fond d'exprimer leur lassitude de
vivre de se dire au fond ça serait aussi
bien qu'on parte comme un geste citoyen
élégant
c'est ce que j'entends c'est leur
crainte donc ça rejoint absolument ce
que ce que je peux parce qu'on arrive à
la fin
ce que je peux vous demander ce que vous
savez de la préparation du texte si
textile lié à enfin voilà ça m'intéresse
pour conclure alors c'est ce que je vais
dire est très politique je sais pas s'il
ne va pas être censurer non non tous en
je me sens pas
j'avais parlé politique donc le
président de la République a mis en
place
une concertation citoyenne
il l'avait déjà fait sur le climat en
lui a reproché à tort ou à raison de ne
pas avoir suivi des avis de cette
consultation citoyenne
cette consultation citoyenne à mon avis
est malmenée elle est menée par des
questionnaires où il y a des séries de
questions oui non oui non oui non c'est
pas comme ça qu'on mène un débat éthique
par la discussion libre voilà la parole
et le temps
si la loi de 2005 elle est passée c'est
parce que après chaque audition en
débriefé on parlait et que il y avait
plus de communistes de socialiste de
droite ou de centre il y avait que des
gens qui parlaient et petit à petit ce
cheminement de doute aboutit
un avis c'est une démarche éthique c'est
pas la démarche qu'on a choisi donc à la
fin ils vont dire on leur a déjà fait
dire d'ailleurs qu'ils étaient d'accord
avec l'aide active à mourir donc au fond
le président est déjà dans une situation
un peu complexe puisqu'il demande un
avis au peuple c'est un avis mais on lui
renvoie sa vie
le CCNE caricaturalement on lui a ouvert
une brèche à ouvert une brèche et la
brèche qu'il a ouvert c'est le suicide
assisté pourquoi le suicide insisté
parce que le tanazi il faut demander à
Claire d'aller donner la mort aux
malades et elle va dire non et
l'ensemble des soignants vont dire non
en sont des soignants vont dire la main
qui soigne peut pas avoir l'ambiguïté de
la main qui tue et donc chez moi non
alors on va essayer de dire finalement
quel est l'autre issue et tous les pays
aujourd'hui qui légalisent le droit à
mourir sont des pays qui légalisent le
suicide assisté
pourquoi parce que dans le conflit
éthique entre l'éthique de vulnérabilité
c'est la société c'est l'hôpital on
soigne on accompagne et personne ne dira
que c'est bips pas bien et donc tous les
toutes les lois il y a la main sur le
cœur en disant et on va développer le
plan numéro 5 des soins palliatifs et de
l'autre côté l'autonomie de la personne
et bien monsieur vous voulez mourir
après tout le suicide c'est une liberté
depuis 1792 ça n'est pas un péché et ça
n'est pas sanctionné pourquoi je
pourrais pas aider quelqu'un à quelque
chose qui est pas illégal
je caricature sauf que c'est une loi
c'est un droit liberté je peux le faire
mais si je te dis je vais me jeter dans
la scène en sortant tu vas essayer de
m'en empêcher
si un des médecins me ramène sur le quai
ils vont me réanimer contre mon avis
donc c'est l'éthique de la vulnérabilité
de la société qui dit fraternellement je
t'empêche voilà un homme ça s'empêche
donc dans cette situation là on va
prendre le suicide assister pas par
hasard que
l'Académie de médecine
m'invite à parler du suicide assisté que
cet après-midi
on m'invite à l'école de magistrature
pour parler du suicide assisté que le
comité d'éthique réfléchit
sur le suicide assisté donc tiens il y a
des coïncidences comme disait l'élève
intelligent
coïncidence et quand deux choses qui
devraient pas coïncider coïncide là il y
a beaucoup de choses qui coïncident en
même temps donc celui-ci on a plusieurs
modèles tu as un modèle suisse est un
modèle
américain le modèle suisse je parle sur
le contrôle de clair qui sait ça mieux
que moi le modèle suisse une association
vient chez toi l'histoire suisse est
assez cocasse c'est un militaire qui
demande à son ordonnance de lui donner
un revolver pour se tuer l'ordonnance
donne le revolver l'officier se tue et
les Suisses décident que finalement
c'est pas interdit à condition que la
motivation ne soit pas égoïste le terme
utilisé et curieux donc c'est une
association qui vient donne le breuvage
à heure fixe à l'heure qui choisit le
malade le bois quelquefois on le filme
pour bien montrer que c'est lui qui le
boit et que on ne l'impolit impose pas
bien entendu il y a d'une démarche
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il s'est passé
que le Suisse assister puisque c'est
quelqu'un qui dit ma vie ne vaut pas la
peine d'être vécue quelqu'un qui dit la
souffrance est intolérable
bien au départ on dit c'est les gens qui
vont mourir et puis après on dit mais
c'est aussi les gens qui souffrent c'est
aussi les handicapés c'est aussi des
malades psychiatriques et donc on
élargit petit à petit le champ parce que
c'est très difficile de dire à toi tu y
as droit et toi tu y as pas droit
pourquoi toi tu aurais pas droit parce
que c'est un droit ouvert
alors il y a le système américain de
l'Orégon qui est le système américain de
l'Orégon que le caricature c'est
quelqu'un qui a 6 mois à vivre je le
caricature complètement
le pronostic vital est engagé à moyen
terme c'est-à-dire nous quand on a fait
la loi on a dit à court terme on peut
endormir les malades à moyen terme c'est
quelques semaines que moi voilà et là il
peut dire je vais mourir dans quelques
mois mais je veux pas passer
par ce passage voilà je
rappelle d'ailleurs que dans l'Évangile
même le Christ aux oliviers augmente des
oliviers dit un sujet de boire ce calice
de sang ça veut bien dire que il y a un
moment où la perspective de la fin de
vie peut faire horreur surtout si on est
abandonné et qu'on souffre donc celui là
on lui donne des pilules et kill pearls
voilà il est propre
il est réclame on les lui donne il les
met dans la poche
60% les prennent 40% les prennent pas
ça veut dire que jusqu'au bout celui qui
a voulu mourir peut encore change encore
d'avis ce qui arrive pas en Suisse donc
la ministre
délégué est allé voir ce qui s'est passé
à l'Oregon et on s'oriente vers la
possibilité de l'orégan à la France on
va remettre quelques garde-fous ici ou
là voilà donc je pense que l'entonnoir
est l'arbre voilà
stratégiquement on chope pas le corps
médical puisque c'est à l'extérieur on
respecte l'autonomie puisque c'est le
suicide assisté c'est le suicide et
on respecte la vulnérabilité et la
fraternité puisque l'hôpital continue et
les soins palliatifs continuent à se
développer
voilà
je l'ai dit donc je redis voilà
quelqu'un veut ajouter quelque chose sur
l'évolution oui c'est juste pour
rebondir sur ce que vous disiez je pense
que dans la question du de l'euthanasie
versus suicide assisté moi je veux dire
qui pourrait être vu comme un moindre
mal au-delà de pas choqué le corps
médical
il y a aussi quelque chose du lien au
patient ce que moi je peux témoigner des
histoires récentes c'est que les gens
ont peur qu'on abrège leur vie et ça
c'est du quotidien moi j'ai il y a pas
très longtemps une jeune femme qui m'a
appelé qui est venue à moi pas parce que
j'étais médecin soit pas actif mais
parce que j'étais la cousine de
danzémailleurs copains et donc par un il
est presque venue là sans le savoir et
elle elle me décrit la situation de son
mari qui était un homme de 45 ans entre
un manifestement de mourir à la maison
et elle était désemparée parce que ça
n'allait pas pour X et Y raison et quand
après l'avoir écouté je commence à me
faire une idée et je lui dis je pense
que ce qu'il faudrait vraiment il
souhaitait rester à maison c'est que
vous puissiez avoir accès à une équipe
de soins palliatifs à la maison me dire
non je crois que c'est pas vraiment le
moment encore en tout cas elle me
racontait je me doute bien qu'il y a
quelque chose derrière je lui fais dire
les choses lui dites quoi pour vous les
soins palliatifs vous imaginez quoi elle
me dit bah c'est l'endroit où on abrège
les choses et donc j'ai pu lui expliquer
et du coup elle m'a dit fin de la
conversation elle m'a dit ah mais en
fait je crois qu'il faudrait qu'il ait
une équipe de sympathique à la maison et
donc je sais pas si il a pu y accéder il
est mort quelques jours après mais cette
femme là je pense en partie elle
bloquait
l'accès à une équipe de soins palliatifs
à son mari en toute bonne foi la pauvre
parce qu'elle pensait qu'on allait
abréger les choses donc je pense qu'il y
a à la fois le fait de évidemment pas
choquer les médecins et les soignants en
général mais il y a aussi préserver ce
lien que les passions ils puissent venir
chez nous en toute confiance je vous
raconte cette histoire c'est la dernière
dit à moi mais j'en ai plein d'autres de
ce style là où qu'ils veulent dire la
même chose les gens pardon ils ont
besoin de
d'être sûr que de ce qu'on va leur faire
ou ce qu'on va pas leur faire et ça
c'est vraiment important aussi
c'est permanent c'est à dire que dès que
les lois commencent à être discutées les
gens ont très peur parce qu'ils ont pas
de papier ils sont à la ils se disent
mais on va on va pas me donner soin et
on va me donner donc ça c'est vraiment
en effet une peur très très fréquent je
vous laisse juste rajouter du Canada est
intéressante sur le suicide c'est Canada
c'est pas la France et c'est un modèle
qui est moins solidaire que la France
mais leur premier résultat montre qu'ils
ont de aidé au suicide au minorité
ethniques et au plus pauvres parce que
même quand on est en fin de vie il vaut
mieux être riche et il vaut mieux être
entouré que que l'inverse et si je si je
suis pardon il vaut mieux être homme
aussi
c'est pas étonnant les femmes ont plus
tendance à se sacrifier pour le bien de
pour le bien de la famille
les hommes sont partis avant donc elles
sont pas accompagnés
plus là oui je voulais aussi ajouter un
point effectivement le suicide assisté
comme vous le disiez en dans votre
premier intervention c'est un moindre
mal mais ça reste un mal parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un souci légitime de ne
pas brutaliser les soignants en leur
imposant de pratiquer des euthanasies
mais même si c'est le suicide assisté
pour le reste de la société ce sera un
peu la même chose c'est-à-dire que que
l'on prenne une pilule ou qu'on prenne
autre chose
ce sera on peut se dire qu'effectivement
dans les EHPAD on va la demander cette
pilule partout où on est isolé partout
où on est seul le moins les personnes
que j'ai rencontrées qui me demandaient
la mort elles étaient invariablement
isolées et donc cette question
toutes les questions autres que
l'implication des soignants et encore
que demander à un soignant de se balader
avec une poche de produits qu'on va
percer c'est pas neutre non plus comme
actes même si c'est pas lui qui tourne
le robinet à la fin et le CCNE a déjà
ouvert la voie à la suite du
raisonnement c'est à dire qu'on est
consultatif
mais par principe d'égalité pour les
personnes qui ne sont pas en mesure de
pratiquer l'acte même il faudra
envisager la possibilité de le faire et
donc on voit déjà que la mécanique est
annoncé on va dire on va dire qu'on se
contente du suicide assisté puis les
personnes qui ne peuvent pas ça va
commencer à être très très large
et puis ensuite on en arrive moi j'ai on
avait participé à une émission commune
avec
on était sidéré d'entendre un
gériâtre Hollandais Bert Kaiser auquel
le journaliste dit est-ce que vous
n'avez pas le sentiment qu'il y a une
pente glissante
et
je croyais pas mes oreilles il répond
oui trois fois oui et ce n'est pas un
mâle on est sur une pente glissante
c'est vrai qu'il y a 14 ans on
euthanasier les gens qui avaient des
souffrances réfractaires aujourd'hui on
euthanasie des gens qui ont des
souffrances psychologiques et on va
toujours ajouter des nouvelles
catégories et je pense pas que ce soit
une mauvaise chose et c'était pas une
déclaration de circonstances j'ai depuis
en recherchant je parle très mal le
Hollandais mais on a des outils de
traduction c'est une position qui tient
et lui pratique des euthanasies depuis
14 ans et dans tous les pays qui ont
légalisé on n'a pas cessé d'élargir les
à l'euthanasie
oui dans une société qui va vieillir qui
va avancer en âge dans les 10 ans qui
viennent on aura plus 40 7%, 75 ans plus
57% de plus de 85 ans il y a un vrai
sujet du de l'accompagnement et de
prendre soin de cette population qui
vieillit dans les EHPAD 75% des gens qui
sont admis ont des maladies neuro
évolutives
à une période le CCNE avait dit on
pourrait envisager l'exception
d'euthanasie et c'était quand si car le
président et ensuite quand Sicard a fait
la mission à la demande du président
Hollande il a pas remis et il a pas
remis parce que dans la discussion qu'on
a eu on a eu la réflexion que vous dites
si on met l'exception devient la norme
alors c'est lui-même qu'il a dit c'était
assez intelligent il a dit si
l'exception devient la norme il y aura
une autre exception à la norme et c'est
ce qu'on voit effectivement dans tous
les pays où
on pousse la limite de la transgression
puis ensuite on a une autre alors
moi j'ai pas souvent été transgressif
surtout parce que j'ai soigné des
malades qui qui mourraient en
s'étouffant et que par bonheur les
médicaments qu'on leur donnait pour qui
s'étouffent pas été de malade qui les
prolongé en même temps donc
ça marchait bien quoi ça collait bien
mais le
dans le cheminement il y a le malade à
un moment donné il dit docteur quand ça
sera le moment vous vous ferez ce qu'il
faut faire et l'engagement très
hypocrites mais en même temps très très
confiant c'est de dire je ferai je serai
toujours là et je ferai ce qu'il faut
faire après on dit pas ce qu'il faut
faire et il y a pas beaucoup de malade
qui m'ont dit vous me donnerez la mort
et mais ils m'ont tous demandé vous
ferez ce qu'il faut faire vous me
laisserez pas comme un légume enfin tes
phrases là on les a entendu
on laisserait pas un poids pour ma
famille etc cet engagement et qui est
l'engagement du soignant il faut qu'elle
revienne quoi et que que le type qui dit
ça la femme qui dit ça ils assument il
assume que au dernier moment
je suis pas un saint loin d'être un sage
mais moi j'allais voir les malades quand
ils mourraient la nuit
on faisait appeler parce que à ce
moment-là j'avais le de d'être là il y a
pas un moment où le malade est plus pour
moi et ça c'est la vieille médecine la
médecine ou le type il opère puis
ensuite
il y a des métastases la maladie plus
pour moi il est pour les infirmières que
l'on vous disiez voilà où il est pour
les les consolateurs des soins
palliatifs mais moi je suis en
chirurgien cette vision là elle est
morte c'est fini voilà médecine c'est
on n'a pas on n'a pas le feu des dieux
je raconte toujours cette histoire
idiote mais qui qui me fait toujours
sourire la différence entre Dieu et un
rédimateur c'est que Dieu sait jamais
pris pour un animateur
[Musique]
de l'Éternel jeunesse et
Ulysse il a la quarantaine ça fait un
moment qui tourne et il dit au revoir
Pénélope mais enfin Pénélope elle est
presque ménopausée donc il
tombe amoureux de cette fille et ils
vivent 7 ans de bonheur parfait au bout
de 7 ans elle lui dit si tu veux parce
que comment savoir qu'il y a un peu
c'est intéressant pas trop et elle avait
une copine qui avait épousé un humain et
l'humain était devenu un vieillard à la
fin donc elle avait dit c'est elle lui
dit si tu veux je te donne l'immortalité
l'immortalité et la jeunesse éternelle
et lui dit non
il se met sur le berge au maire dit se
met sur la berger il pleure
il veut rentrer chez lui et Camus qui
est le plus grand philosophe du monde et
qui interprète ça il dit c'est la fierté
de l'acceptation de nos limites voilà
être humain c'est mourir voilà c'est un
jour mourir et cette fierté de fragilité
elle fait partie de notre dignité elle
est inaltérable c'est parce qu'on est
vulnérable qu'on est humain si on était
des fois je disais
vous êtes comme vous voulez voilà alors
toutes les filles je sais pas comment
elles sont tous les mecs sont des bras
voilà nous mais nous on est on est pas
Brad Pitt quoi voilà si par bonheur tous
les types étaient des Brad Pitt on
serait extraordinaire parce qu'on serait
le seul à pas être Brad Pitt donc on
aurait dans notre vulnérabilité un
caractère exceptionnel et donc nous
sommes tous exceptionnels parce que nous
savons des défauts et que nous sommes
insuffisants et vulnérable donc faut pas
renoncer à ça et la France peut pas
renoncer
à au soutien la vulnérabilité parce que
c'est c'est la base fondamentale de
l'humanisme voilà si on lâche là dessus
on lâchera sur autre chose et si la
principale transgression c'est qu'on
peut donner la mort au plus faible
après on ira beaucoup plus loin et c'est
parce que nous sommes vulnérables et
interdépendants
nous
de l'amour aussi qui dépasse qui dépasse
la mort
quand il fût de retour en fin dans sa
patrie le saint Julie son vieux chien de
lui se souvint près d'un tapis de haute
lisse sa femme attendait qu'il revint ah
bon
c'est un peu le dur c'est pas mal bon
c'était formidable oui
la capacité d'accompagner avec des
équipes formées et moi je tire juste la
Solidaire parce qu'on parle de l'accès
aux soins palliatifs mais aujourd'hui on
peut se dire que l'accès aux soins tout
court il est extrêmement difficile et
donc c'est pas mon côté
mononuronalgériatrique mais dans une
société qui va vieillir ou l'accès aux
soins est difficile ou le nombre de
ressources humaines et de plus en plus
rares il y a des tentations
potentielles de des raccourcis il faut
que tu mettes la convaincre d'une loi
générale pas d'une loi du simple en tout
cas ça va être un combat intéressant
quand même